in light of the tragedies today in
Nashville uh we just want to say that
um
you know my heart is really just
just broken
as I think a lot of people's are
um you know this happened just right
down the street from me and it's um
it's just heavy man it's it's a it's a
lot
and uh we just wanna
uh
we just want to say that we are
thinking of those people who are
suffering
and um praying for peace uh
and just praying that Comfort finds them
um
and I know people have different
thoughts on prayers and stuff that's
fine I'm not trying to solve the problem
today I'm just trying to take some
moments to out of my own life to think
of other people I guess
um but yeah just wanted to
say that that's on our minds and hearts
over here and
um it's just a heavy it is it has been a
it's been just a heavy time and it's a
fresh heavy thing and that's what's
going on
um and we're grateful to be alive today
and to be able to have a podcast and to
sit and talk with people that we care
about and
um
and that you are alive today to listen
so uh thank you and uh we love you guys
I want to let you know for Touring that
we will be adding dates eventually for
Australia and um Europe
the UK uh everywhere we're adding places
as much as we can
um and trying to stay uh sane and well
at the same time so looking forward to
getting over there I just had a great
week in Houston and Corpus Christi and
um yeah just want to let you guys know
that there are still a few tickets
available for Medford Massachusetts New
York
uh New York Las Vegas
Uncasville Connecticut and Toronto
Ontario all those are available at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r and if some of the tickets get
outrageous not they won't be
outrageously priced through us but if
through resalers they get outrageously
priced then just hold off we'll come
back through so I don't want you guys
spending a ton of money
um
thank you very much for the support
today's guests are two comedians who
have countless years of uh comedy
experience between the two of them
one of them Mike vecchione has a new
special which is out now on YouTubes and
it's called the attractives and it was
produced by Nate bargatzi and that's
where you can watch it on Nate's Channel
and they are both here today Nate is a
household name at this point I'm
grateful to sit down with both of them
today's guests are Mike vecchione and
Nate bargatzi
hey
I'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
how much water you guys having
um for the day I'm trying to have a lot
more
I'm trying to have a gallon
that's one of the biggest things to do
is have water one of the best things you
could
ever do yeah is the most it's seeing how
many people how much people are
dehydrated yeah
yeah you don't even know it but it's
like you should have that lemon water in
the morning first thing you take a lemon
just put it in water and then
NutriBullet and just grind it up and
then chug it it refreshes all your
electrolytes first Are you seriously
yeah oh wow how much a whole lemon in
there just a whole lemon just cut it
peel it and put it in with water and
then just chug it so you take the peel
off yeah
yeah people are dehydrated this science
says we should have a ton of water yeah
yeah people are very hydrated you think
they are I think so I think most I think
I mean the percentage has got to be
85 yeah 100 or not dehydrated oh yeah
yeah I don't know but it could be that
high but it's one of those things too
where it's like you don't realize it you
you're uh that you're that dehydrated
but it's also one of those things where
it's like you're not breathing right
yeah it's one of those things either
it's like you're not you're just a
shallow breather right you know yeah
maybe you're just like burning off all
the water because you don't breathe
you're not getting like the right depth
of air or something yeah I mean they're
not related but it's like one of those
things you just take for granted it's
like I'm getting enough water from
thirsty I drink it and that's how I know
I'm dehydrated you know yeah it's the
same thing it's like yeah there's no
problem with my breathing no no you need
to be doing these deep breaths all the
time he does deep breathing deep
breathing you do yeah he's a big habit I
mean he does we're talking I feel like
you would like talking to him about
getting in some uh there's the structure
this guy has is that habitualness yeah
yeah
um yeah I'm trying to think of how much
water that I have or how much I like
having uh I think I like having it
I think yeah science says that you are
supposed to have a group like a pretty
much
I don't know if a gallon you think you
have a gallon I forget the percentages
of your body but it's yeah
okay let me start I think we already
started mine can we start it's fine yeah
oh my God go to the bathroom I didn't
even want to talk to somebody who I know
as fully no no no no no no we actually
started but it's not cool I think if
somebody's full of pissed yeah no no I'm
not full I was just gonna I was like
thinking it I didn't I would get it out
now we know now we know
what do you think he should do now I
don't know I think I'm fine and waiting
out and if he has to go then he has to
go sit in the car till we're done
like you should have went before Mike so
you didn't I didn't realize now you're
gonna wait in the car but we're done but
I didn't realize we started
well that's how you every podcast we
were doing the headphones back and forth
thing was that on it that might be it
might have been a fun time I don't know
maybe it's a good time to gather some
things yeah yeah you got to listen to
this guy man you got to listen to this
guy
um there's your
uh 15 and a half cups 3.7 liters so like
you know there's like a bottle a liter
bottle liter bottle from uh
um
but I tried to you it would be to try to
drink four liters a day oh my God that's
what I mean you it's so much
that you're uh it's it's just you need
so much water yeah and a these I mean I
drink coffee too but the coffee
dehydrates you he sucks it all I drink a
ton of diet soda uh I love it but it's
all dehydrating oh God and so
everything's dehydrating
we had the water in New York is like
feels like it's heavily treated oh yeah
I don't know like the water here
supposed to like the best still they
have it on top of the building it's they
say it's the best but I I don't know it
feels heavily treated that's when New
York would say you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah
our water's more educated than your
water is yeah that's what that's the
attitude yeah that's the attitude of
them there
dude I had to work I got court ordered
one time to work at this water treatment
facility
um
in Louisiana dude and they're not
people are sleeping on a job yeah yeah
there was some stuff's getting through I
mean you see like a float go through
some trash you see some stuff that you
know I remember seeing people laugh
about the fact that somebody was gonna
try to drink that he don't see he got
out of this picture you have like a
paddle and you're supposed to grab that
trash and you just go that's too far and
you let it go through and it's going out
of someone's sink someone's sink just
flows and they're like it's my water's
not going yeah you got a tire stuck on
the other end of that that's what
yeah man they had a lot of I remember
what in the last tank like the stuff
that's supposed to go out like it's
supposed to be pure whatever I remember
finding a bunch of barrettes in there
and being like Oh God they're not doing
our job barrettes like hair bars and
children or adults I guess yeah yeah why
would people be throwing those away I
work I read water meters did you really
so like the the the the uh depending on
seeing how much water everybody uses no
way yeah and Was it crazy who was using
the most like was it like what ethnicity
do you think was using the most water
women yeah women yeah yeah I would say I
know it's March
but um that was this women's month it's
women's awareness oh it is yeah we
wasn't aware of these [__] dude I'm
[__] yeah and you know they're all I
think about or they're all that I'm
dealing with you know
yeah my wife is better with water than I
am
I will leave it running yeah I'm not
good we're not you know in La is like a
big you're supposed to turn the water
off and blah blah I was not the best at
that
and what do you mean like you'll just
stay in the shower for a long time I
could take long showers uh if I brush my
teeth and I go pee I can leave the water
running and I'll go pee and then come in
what's your mindset there it's just this
like why interrupt the flow of it yeah
turn it on and off yeah you gotta turn
it on and off so it's like you just
leave it running anything where do you
consciously go I hate the earth I do
anything that anything in my head that
thinks this is good for the environment
I do the opposite dude I was like that I
remember whenever they first came with
like electric cars I remember driving
down the road and just pull I had a gas
cell I was just pouring gas driving a
gas powered car and pouring gas out of
my window yeah like out of a gas tank
just like [__] it you're not gonna lose
you're not gonna lose I had and we lost
we lost we lost
uh it was very expensive for you to go
drive around yeah oh yeah double fill up
oh yeah uh we had I had gas I delivered
uh uh mattresses and appliances here in
Nashville uh growing up and uh or when I
was you know 18 19 20. and so we we had
a 26 foot box truck that we did and uh
it got the gas tank the fuel tank uh
because you put diesel in it uh broke
and we're driving down 24 the interstate
here and we didn't realize it but it was
leaking fuel the whole way so I mean
from 100 from we get off we fill it up
and it got punctured somehow I figured
how and then it leaks the whole way and
then we get off and I mean there's just
a trail of diesel and so you'd have to
go when we were driving you'd have to uh
especially do another punch you'd have
to go through uh weigh stations you know
the way you're
truck
and then someone came up and we we the
how we fixed it was just putting duct
tape and spray painted it black over it
and so this lady came and like she was
like a you know an official an officer
that's like checking our truck and I
mean it was eot Department yes yes that
sounds pretty thorough yeah so put black
duct tape over it oh yeah well yeah so
we're driving Italian kind of so me and
my buddy are driving and uh where he and
Jamie Jamie's driving and Jamie uh does
not have a uh I don't think he has a
license and like he says a lot of
criminal stuff so he's driving so we're
he's like oh wait you need to get in the
driver's seat because we're about to
have to go through this weigh station so
in the middle of the interstate I have
to stand up and we switch places now I'm
driving we pull in and then she's like
I'm gonna come check your truck and I'm
like dude she sees that we are fuel tank
because just uh just duct tape like
we're gonna go I don't know what you
might go to jail I don't know what's
going to happen so then I'm like out
like I meet her halfway out and I'm just
trying to stand on like the step to try
to hide the duct tape and we hit it oh
you hit it yeah we didn't see it she
didn't see it what a bad inspector well
see that that would probably be pretty
obvious yeah I don't think they expect
anybody to be doing that I think they
yeah I think that's like low that's like
really Bush it's almost like that would
have happened in like the early practice
trial like this is something nobody will
ever do yeah they go should I check a
duct tape on the fuel tank they're like
nah I've seen that yeah this is you know
it's like yeah these are just like yeah
it's like this is the 2000s now I think
we're in the future so I don't know I
think that stuff's long gone that time
dude I remember one time my brother we'd
been um
we grew up by this River and across from
the river was the back of a rest area by
the interstate and a lot of gay men and
stuff would meet up over there and you
know do or not drug not gay men but they
would do enough drugs where they would
be good yeah yeah like drug-induced gay
right yeah and
um and one time anyway somebody draw a
big wiener on my brother's back right
and we got back to the house and uh and
like we were just trying to like hide it
from like hide the back of my brother
from my mom yeah it just reminded me of
that dude and then when she saw it
finally she got so [__] pissed man we
told her that somebody don't let someone
do that I didn't I mean I couldn't help
it they were adult yeah these were
adults doing it they actually drew it on
his back yeah Drew like a
you know like a wiener or penis yeah but
um
one time we rented a car and the they
got a dent in it and we caught a pigeon
and it made it [__] over the dent to
kind of cover it up
before we turned it in you gotta just
hold it and just I mean you gotta yeah
you gotta squeeze a little yeah yeah to
get it out I just couldn't even catch
the picture then Graham I've never held
a pigeon before but I'm just trying to
avoid that fine yeah yeah but I would
think anybody that could catch a pigeon
it would be it would be you Theo I think
they don't even notice I'm there at
first yeah I think they go you're one of
us they go what's up man there you go
hey when you were squeezing it did you
go you know I hope you had a big lunch
because what pigeons have to go to the
bathroom a lot yeah yeah they're ready
to go you don't have to do much you can
almost even whisper to them they just do
it and the pigeons down here are
probably healthier than the ones like in
New York and other areas New York
pigeons don't look healthy they don't
look like they live in a healthy
lifestyle no I think they're going to
the bathrooms get rough because you're
eating so much yeah regular if you
haven't had enough water you know yeah
yeah other Penguins holding their wings
while they go it's just too it's like a
lot of they need some real help Todd
Glass I've never had a joke about uh a
pigeon you ever see a pigeon he went out
to his car and he goes then this pigeon
must have been like oh God he just let
it go like it was just all over this car
where you're like this guy's the pigeon
stomach was
crushed I couldn't imagine being a
you know one of those real guttural
animals you know like even shrimp hang
out at the bottom of the ocean and just
eat
really probably Duty that comes out of
other fish and
um you know oysters are supposed to be
like sponges that purify the ocean
like the water's supposed to go through
them they're almost like the air filter
for the ocean
and we go and eat them
which is insane I mean it I love them
yeah yeah you know and I don't I you
know but they're aphrodisiac too somehow
aren't they maybe trash isn't
aphrodisiac yeah
oh yeah what does Africa mean
it makes you horny oh yeah that's right
that's what I thought it meant
trying to think of things that make me
horny really
oysters pigeons
water if you have more water oh God
um that's what you need yeah dude so
we're talking about I want to thank you
guys for coming in and hanging out dude
and I was there when you guys taped
Mike's yeah special right it might have
been the last time that I saw you guys
yes right yeah at Zanies at Zanies yeah
yeah I'm excited for this to come out
24th March 24th and so you started produ
like how did you guys kind of figure
this out to to do it
we've been friends for a long time and
um uh Nate moved he he moved to LA
so and then
and then to Nashville so but over the
years like he would come back and do the
Tonight Show so then I would see him and
he would hang out and we would hang out
and stuff so we were just he was like
why don't you come out and open for me I
was like nah I'm headlined whatever and
then as time went on then he was like no
no do a date or two and and and and and
so then I started going out on the road
with him and then when we were on the
road he was like Hey I wanna it was his
idea like if you do an hour like I'll
direct it and produce it yeah well
Mike's unreal yeah and and and so one of
the best Comics I love you watching the
tape yeah it's it's it's it's so good
and it'll be on my YouTube on uh March
24th but it's so good and it's like
you're seeing this we we talked a lot
about this last night like the way like
you know it's all kind of going now with
specials or you're like doing stuff like
that and I'm clean and uh comic so like
this special mic is going to be clean
like
because it's like that just kind of my
world is like kind of that and it's yeah
but it's like for clean comics they're
not they don't get the level of comic
the Mike is like usually like clean is
you know it's basically just being like
TV you know we had to did Comedy Central
stuff you did a half hour you did all
this you had to be TV clean yeah back
when you did that stuff so it's kind of
making stuff like that uh but putting
specials out because we got his coming
out then Greg Warren and Joe Zimmerman
is we taped I take three hours and so
it's just being super fun and super
funny it's what I think you do well as
you know where it's you're super fun
when people go see you live and the
thing that I've always told you you love
your fans you love the people that come
out to see you I this is my favorite
thing is that you know afterwards you
you go and you're with all of them and
you're just the love you have for these
people and the love they have for you is
something that's I is it's getting lost
in entertainment and it's being there's
such a disconnect with some with a lot
of things where people like
they're not just they they I don't know
they don't have they don't you're you're
people are paying to go to these shows
and all the stuff you're like show them
their respect to give them a good show
and be just entertainment and be fun be
a break for everybody no one needs this
everything doesn't need to be this super
heavy kind of thing or this I'm smarter
than you I know this and I know you know
it's like just go be in pure
entertainment for them and that's what I
want to do and that's what his special
is going to do you know and like Greg's
and Joe's where it's just like it's
being fun again like make things be fun
I think stuff is like I said two
too heavy two people got like they're
too smart for you know that's a good
point everybody feels so smart now since
we all have well smartness kind of
adjusted because we all have everybody
has the same access to stuff now so it
used to be somebody had to be smart yes
now somebody just pulls up something
they believe that somebody else has an
actual like like a circumference of that
knowledge or like an i a a full look at
it and they just say well look at this
you know everybody if you have a good
memory you can be you can come off as
the smartest person ever because you
could just say all the things and then I
like I'm trying to do a joke about I
didn't go to college and so I'm trying
to do a joke about college now but not
that I'm against College uh but it's
like I didn't go I feel like college is
the they just you go to learn big words
and so then you they they people just
say these big words and then someone
that like I didn't go to college so I
don't know these big words and so then
you're just like feel like you're out of
a conversation because you're like well
I don't know what that word means oh yes
and went in dropped a big one on you
yeah which is and then you're just like
well I don't know this so then you're
like you feel dumb yeah and then you're
like but I think we I can talk what
you're saying I just don't know the word
I don't know all those words yeah but I
feel like people are flexing on you yes
oh yeah yeah that's the worst huh
I went to College I went to Penn State
oh did you really yeah yeah very
arrogant yeah I pride myself on talking
down to those who didn't go yeah that's
what he does
less than yeah dude I'm trying to think
diminished is a word maybe you know but
that means less is that good oh that's
less than I thought that was a positive
thing for me diminished yeah it sounds
Japanese it does
um if you put the accents you say that
right in front of the American flag how
do you feel about this yeah
this past weekend is brought to you by
betterhelp
you know getting to know yourself can be
a lifelong journey
you know we talk about that a lot on
here and and heck it's I'm still
figuring it all out and I know I'm not
the only one
and therapy helps me it's helped me a
lot over the years I still go every
Friday at 3 P.M
and therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding
because sometimes we don't know what we
want or what's going on or we can't get
a good look at ourselves if we're the
only ones looking at ourselves
better help connects you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge discover
your potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 percent off your
first month that's betterhelp.com
Theo to get 10 percent off your first
month it's springtime baby and it's time
to tidy up
It's Time to Get It Up in them crevasses
baby and trim about around your wiener
dog you know it
de-hair that wean baby get it nice buddy
let the wind hit it
you know what I'm talking about
manscaped
that's right join the other eight
million men who trust manscaped use code
Theo to get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
they got a beautiful performance package
4.0 that you can groom your body with
and you can get that ball care bundle
baby the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed
whacker does the ear and hair nose
trimmer get all in it God get it out if
you purchase now you will receive two
free gifts the performance boxer briefs
and shed travel bag you can make sure
you gotta everything to take care of
your bag is in a bag baby that's it
save 20 off and free shipping with code
Theo at manscape.com that's 20 off in
free shipping with code t-h-e-o at
manscaped.com your balls well thank you
you know I'm a big fan of Raising Cane's
you know it
them chicken fingers boy gosh
makes me wish every chicken had a
thousand hands on it that's how tasty
they are
and that dipping sauce badal
and I put it inside of me they're good
the Texas toast that's buttered up and
they got them crinkle cut fries baby
dang like somebody just remixed a
regular fry and they're tasty
and I got to tell you this I like the
Caniac combo that's my choice
so now that your mouth is watered up
I gotta tell you it's easy to order
canes on their mobile app or online at
raising canes.com
satisfy your Cane's fix fast by ordering
through their app or online at raising
canes.com or stop by your local
restaurant
um you know I like it canes
um so that's the special so to be out on
the 24th yeah and were you nervous doing
it because I remember being there that
night I'm trying to think you had on a
black like long sleeve yeah that's the
funny thing like uh Nate dressed me
completely I'm not I'm not ashamed to
say that another uh grown man dressed me
Complete because I don't really know how
to dress I'm I have bad he didn't wear
anything crazy but it was like I gave
him like a I had a black sweater yeah it
looked like a safe bet yeah yeah I'm
just I go very basic colors just I don't
know what I'm doing so yeah he uh put a
little effort he had that rehab
graduation Vibe it was almost like hey
this guy's graduating his family's
coming to see him it did have that yeah
yeah it's like it goes you go come on
man you're doing but you're doing better
your mom bought you that she laid it out
for you you're reintroducing yourself to
the family because the last time they
saw you was a nightmare it was a
nightmare so you're reintroducing to
your family your mom lays it out you've
seen your grandmother again last time
you saw her you called her some names so
you know and you and you show up and it
looks like this rehab's not gonna take
like it was like this this one is you're
gonna go back yeah but this is your
first one back out yeah this is this
you're like a newborn baby yeah that's
it yeah we'll keep it we'll keep a
bottle near you
the dress was uh was huge it was I don't
like to have to think about I understand
why people wear the same thing thing
every day oh it's like you don't have to
think about it you just like put it on
yeah and put it on like um I think about
that all the time I love that wear the
same thing every day yeah yeah I tell on
stage I wear the same thing for the past
two years maybe or three maybe three
four years almost now yeah it's just the
easiest yeah black shirt and black pants
yeah the same exact ones yeah it's just
easy for me I can't if I get too much
opportunities to think about stuff I
don't do well yeah I I agree I don't I
don't but I think about it I think about
it just in regular life like just here
like just buy this same stuff wear it
everywhere and then
that's it you know it's a lot of
decisions yeah yeah you need to get
decisions out of your life and one color
too I think that's one thing the Black
Culture does well they do they'll be
like one color like today Larry is
fuchsia yeah right you know and it's top
full future like can't even [__]
fight for the [__] Fusion military
yeah he will there is no he's eating
Asian Fusion for lunch there's no like
he is full fuchsia for that day you
couldn't [__] if you came near him
with a little bit of [__] lavender
yeah or a little bit of [__]
Tangerine he'll be my [__] he'll Flex
on you yeah you know that is true
but they've mastered the art of that
let's make you kind of let's keep it
simple you know
you go with a good cologne a [__]
sturdy cologne and you go one color
do you wear cologne I don't wear anymore
I think cologne these days kind of
signifies you're trying to hide
something yeah you've obviously been I
think
I think it's kind of two things either
you've never looked at pornography or
you've been cheating on your spouse a
cologne is a good sign that you're
cheating yeah yeah that is I think
that's correct actually you wear a
cologne no I wear ax body spray do you
really because I'm not ready to cheat
but I still want to smell pungent yeah I
think pungent is a good Nate do you get
punching uh it's not good I'd imagine
it's an aggressive smell you spray X
body spray yeah really Mike yeah at the
gym
I have a girlfriend and I have a
you know I have a family but not in the
sense that uh like traditional men have
families like a wife and kids yeah I
have a mother and a brother and a sister
but I have a girlfriend yes you have an
original family we don't have your own
family yeah yeah that's a good way to
put original yeah
my original family yeah he's very uh
he's very put together he wrestled at
Penn State yeah you did but I wrestled
for one year I wrestled for one year so
uh you're on the team I went through the
training and everything and the second
year I was like I can't I can't do this
this is so much work this was the it was
so much this was the 60s go ahead
of it well when Lyndon Johnson got it
this is where black people allowed to
wrestle go ahead Mike oh yeah you only
had a couple of white tattoo yeah
we all made the Penn State team I guess
but
um yeah after the first year I was like
this is I mean the guys were so good it
was so the training was so tough
sometimes we have to work out three
times a day and and uh it was just I'm
like I can't wrap my head around it so I
didn't do it and then I really enjoyed
the rest of my college career because I
was friends with a lot of those guys and
I lived with them and so I had a great
time just not having to do the punishing
punishing I still love the sport yeah
but uh to be honest like I didn't I
wasn't good enough to be there really I
placed in States and uh High School
where I was from that's why I was good
for my area which is Florida which was
wasn't I started wrestling in Ohio and
then placed in States in Florida where I
went to high school and so I was good
for my area but
we were number three in the country the
year that I wrestled there and uh we had
just all Americans and national champs
all up and down the lineup so it was
just going to practice was just taking
beatings every day
but you know I learned a lot mental
toughness all that stuff so it was great
it was a great experience you think you
could be like Bobby Lee says that he
wrestled in
I don't know what he was in an
internment camp or something but he said
that he wrestled at some point he had to
rest yeah yeah he had no choice yeah he
probably wrestled for you know oranges
or whatever they had for dinner but do
you think you could bring up Bobby Lee
into wrestling there you go I think you
could beat him in a wrestling uh I don't
know his background like I wasn't the
best athlete in the world and I also
wasn't the best technician I I had I
worked when I was when I was on teams I
would really work hard and I was like
hard-nosed so I can't say that about
myself yeah but that's how I describe
his comedy hard enough he's not well no
he's not the best at everything but he
is he does show up and that's and that's
how people come see when people buy
tickets just know it's not gonna be the
best show you've ever seen But Nate but
Mike will show up he's like a union
worker
so bring it back up I want to see that
picture you don't be honest with me I
don't know y'all be in different weight
classes yeah we're different ways I
don't know let's get a current picture
of Bobby leave in and see if we could
there you go I could tell you um I could
tell you if I could win by knowing his
background what state did he wrestle in
and how California is a a California is
a wild card State you could be real
there's like really good guys he
wouldn't think California is a good
State it's not good as Pennsylvania or
Ohio or Iowa but it is very good that's
an actual picture of him during the
tournament yeah so bring up that picture
yeah
okay could you beat
and don't get confused with his brother
just bring up a current picture of Bobby
Lee
let's get real I just want to get to the
truth here Mike because people are going
to come see you they want to see the
truth yeah they want to see exactly can
you beat this guy zoom in on this man
please
can you beat this guy in wrestling
can I beat him in wrestling
honestly it's real easy right well right
now maybe yeah because I'm in uh I'm in
decent shape now you're running
wrestling
this guy's focus it definitely is more
of a tapas
I think uh uh the other guy we did or uh
Greg Warren especially coming after that
he wrestled uh from Missouri
oh my God Nate is doing nothing but
wrestlers specials yeah well they just
have the national championship film this
weekend I think Penn State is unreal now
Joe Zimmerman College golfer
yeah but they're but uh uh uh Greg
Warren wrestled with Michael Chandler's
brother or like I think so Mike all
right I say this on every podcast
because people and you know the comedy
communities small they go you wrestled
Greg Russell who would win who would win
I'm like Greg was on another level he
was an All-American he was that great he
was really really did y'all come across
that fox catcher guy
oh no that guy was that was happening
when I was um in school but yeah no I
um I saw that movie that was crazy he
was he was out of his mind that was the
that was when you were that's when I was
in college yeah but those guys would go
like the guys the top guys on the team
would go train at foxcatcher because for
the Olympics and stuff and what was that
guy was touching people or he was
abusing them I don't know about that
like I don't know the facts or
everything but I can't imagine good yeah
yeah I can't imagine I don't even know I
don't know anything about it I can't
imagine him doing that to this level of
wrestlers like touching them and and
being like not having any repercussions
wrestlers are not they don't stable
people and they're not gonna play I
don't care how much money the guy has so
I I can't see him like being predatory
against these types of guys yeah these
types of guys are very very tough guys
yeah and I know the guy's a billionaire
and all that stuff but you know when
somebody you know fondles you that all
that goes out the window maybe not for
you guys I don't know yeah but for me
like would you have trouble with it
would you right now just be saying well
he was a different weight class so I had
to I had to go with it yeah yeah what if
he just does a naked naked choke and
you're like this I don't think this is a
yeah you're naked naked yeah yeah look
at this dude
um so now you're helping produce three
specials yes okay and are they all
coming out again like is it to be
sequential like should people yeah yeah
it's like March 24th I want to say
roughly a month month okay yeah sweet
something like that all on my on my
YouTube yeah that's awesome but it's
like guys that have been around like you
know
Mike's done specials Mike's done
everything and it's uh you know we were
talking about like last night about
where the specials are going where it's
just such a different thing now there's
not uh uh and we might uh I'm gonna be
doing something else too they're filming
something with like uh newer some newer
Comics some not where it's like kind of
alive at Gotham kind of nice thing but
it's uh you know Comics if you're
starting now as a comic uh what do you
it's like what do you got to do like for
us we were we did live at Gotham I think
we did it all the same time uh didn't we
all do live without you and I did it
around the same Australia we did it the
same year I think we did the same year
2008 powers in 2010 we did half hours
this year wow in Boston did y'all shoot
yours no no I shot mine in New York oh
you did so you were Boston yeah yeah but
we were all about the same yeah same
time and so like we there was a path
that Comics had to take right where we
did you know live at Gotham he did half
hours economy Central hour and then you
know then Netflix came but now for young
Comics you're like I don't know what you
have to do like there's no
uh you can try to do a late night Set uh
but outside of that you're like I mean
an hour Netflix like you know there's
not I get Netflix did some yeah 15
minute stuff yeah stand up wise there's
nowhere to go there used to be steps to
measure yourself okay I'm gonna show you
I did my eight minutes on live at Gotham
now I'm shooting for this half hour it's
like I didn't get a half hour this year
it's like all right let me tighten it up
and like try again next year like there
was some ethics to like you know
progressing now it's just like let me
try to get on Tick Tock and have a video
go and then do an hour like then the
first step is an hour and that's uh
that's not the best wow yeah that's a
that's a strange Fleck to a lot of
people think that you you think a lot of
companies feel like they need to like do
an hour now no no I don't think I I mean
I think that's the first thing they put
out isn't it the first thing they put
out is an hour and guys have been doing
comments like you know the the thing
with him and Greg and Joe is like these
are guys have been doing comedy for 20
years oh yeah and so I've been doing it
for 20 years too like so it's like we've
been doing it for long times he's been
doing it for a long time so it's like
you're showing him to go do an hour
you're like yeah dude he can do he can
headline he does an hour but then
there's Comics that are newer and it's
like I mean their only Outlet is to be
like well I got clicks on Tick Tock or
whatever
I'll put out an hour and you're like man
it's it's it's hard to build up to be
able to do an hour you know headlining
like it's not an easy thing like it's uh
but guys are going from they have a
couple clips and it's to then just
putting out a full hour and I think the
discipline of um working in the clubs
the way that we all worked in the clubs
is now
it's not totally out the window but I
don't think we had no choice but to
grind in the clubs for years and years
and that's not a thing anymore it's not
as big of a thing as it used to be it's
interesting because you know podcasts
and Tick Tock and Instagram it's like oh
this is where I'm gonna
have myself because why am I why am I in
the clubs every single night right you
can be Loosely funny now versus having
to be when you're on stage it's like no
it needs to be exact right because
you're an audience is there and it's an
immediate reaction and now you can it
seems like you can shoot a bunch of
videos and then you just finally pick
one that works or you know whatever it
is yeah
sorry guys my
stepdad's in the hospital not really he
actually passed away a couple years ago
but
he um but he would be nice my mom thinks
about him a lot yeah yeah he would still
be in the hospital if he was alive today
probably he probably would he was a
warrior he was a union guy oh yeah if he
didn't give up he showed up wow even in
a coma he was there every [__] day
yeah non-responsive yeah yeah clocking
in clock
we like to call it active listening yeah
that's active listening is another
positive way to say non-responsive you
think you that would you go get it all
out dude because a guy like that if you
have a dad like that he probably didn't
you get to talk to him that much yeah so
when he finally gets that coma you're
like go let it out oh that's a great
podcast idea coma chatter yeah you just
yeah yeah bring uh sons in that never
got to tell their dad they love them or
something and then yeah I've thought a
lot about that like a special I thought
a lot about
you know I did this ketamine therapy
where I got to and there was a there was
a moment during it where I actually got
to spend time with my dad right like as
real as you and I are sitting right here
that says real as it felt on any sensory
level right which is crazy I wouldn't
just say that I'm not a guy you know I
don't know ghosts or anything like that
I'm not that guy but I got to spend time
with them for maybe about like what felt
like maybe a minute or two minutes where
he was it was as real as any sense of
mine ever knew that anybody was real
yeah so I think it'd be interesting if
you had I thought if they had like
mannequins or something where you could
bring your parents old clothing or
something or if your buddy got hit by a
truck or something or you know drove in
like an embankment or something and died
or something he was peeled up but you
could go bring their stuff and then you
spend time almost with the mannequin or
maybe you put all of it into like a
machine and the Machine creates a
hologram of them and then you get to
like like I wonder if they'll have that
kind of stuff in the future you know or
a place where you get to to redo the
dad's coma you know and there's like a
fake dad in there laying in there some
guys like the new Santa or whatever at
the mall and he clocks in and you go in
and you [__] sit by the bed for 40
minutes or whatever and get it out but
it's ketamine a hallucinogen
tranquilizer
is that what it is I wouldn't be shocked
dude
I used to do that on stage I'd be like
are you guys all on ketamine and then
because you guys feel like tired cats uh
why do you want to feel like a tired cat
I don't know I didn't know it was a
hallucigen I thought that was like acid
or
um what's the other thing that's like
acid but it's safer and everybody
does it now you can do it you have to
you can go to a place and do it and um
oh the thing Aaron Rodgers did yeah it's
like that kind of thing
Ayahuasca yeah oh I felt like that was
like a bitmoji stuck in the back of like
a
like uh I remember one time thinking I
was like a like a gigabyte or something
stuck in the back corner of like a um
Foot Locker like I was [__] out there
though and where do you do this at like
in a room yeah just in a chill room like
you like you go somewhere to do it
there's like a therapist in there with
you so it's like guided meditation while
you're doing it so you did that yeah
that was pretty cool if you're just
shooting up at a [__] outside of a
Jimmy John's or whatever I don't think
that's the way to you know right yeah I
wasn't doing this yeah that's the old
school right yeah yeah that was for the
freelance version yeah yeah but this is
more a little bit more sanctioned but um
to get back what you're saying yeah I
think I think it would be interesting if
they had like kind of reenactment stuff
where you could go through and redo it
is that what we're talking about Comas
how are we getting it yeah yeah the I
like your podcast idea of going to
somebody with a coma that you have a lot
to get out and they're in a coma now and
you could just tell everything just go
40 minutes you know just go 40 five
minutes just talking about your feelings
with no nothing coming back
because sometimes you need that you just
post the whatever the relationship
whatever the relationship is and then
you just go right into it but I don't
know if hospice will be cool with it but
also if you could get a blip on their
thing you'd [__] that would be it
it'd be like blip hunters and we go and
we sit with somebody's in a coma and
they have their line or whatever on
their heart reading right and if you can
[__] get them to blip or something
you know you got through that person
wins yeah that's great turn it into a
and if he doesn't if you don't get a
blip then you're like this guy's good
yeah like he doesn't feel anything he's
like no no he's uh he's willing yeah it
would be
if you knew you were gonna
die and still not give up anything in at
all
man that's it's a strong person
you had to go to the Grave with
something right yeah I don't know if I'd
go to the Grave with all my secrets
you got to tell him that somebody tell
them to a nephew right tell them to
somebody who doesn't you know
and throw that all on a nephew like a
young nephew oh a nephew's just a time
capsule for your [__] I feel like
you know yeah a nephew yeah it's like
someone that's like I didn't really know
my uncle and then I really knew my uncle
but like just right before he died
Unleashed on me and now I gotta carry
that around that's my mom he was talking
about
like just a lot it's just a lot to throw
on a nephew but it's got to go somewhere
you know what I mean
um to get back to kind of what you guys
were saying about like yeah I think
having clips and stuff obviously is
helpful to people these days I think
people more than ever want to see uh
some person a person get to know a
person in their personality yeah you
know I think it's even what's nice about
being involved in like podcasting worlds
yeah
um
is that people want to get to know
something because for so long it was so
formulaic it was like you just got this
person
um that had kind of been through this
system and the system was all kind of
dictated and that's who kind of got to a
level where people were able to see
their work right you know and now I
think
um people are wanting to get to know
people more right maybe hypothetically
I'm guessing yeah and then so they
listen to podcasts and they get to know
people they get to know people that are
on the episodes It's a pretty small
Universe after a while yeah right and
then um
and so then they feel a little bit more
connection so then when they're sitting
in the audience they're also getting to
see this person yeah yeah uh this person
and not just the material
um
they get to know where it kind of comes
from right yeah I think they you know I
sat in the audience one night I was
watching uh um
I was watching a guy who a podcaster and
I was like oh a lot of the audience I
could feel it they're just excited to be
here in the room with me right yeah oh
yeah you know it was cool and I even
thought I was like man yeah this is cool
we're literally just hanging out with
them here with if the material is good
or bad yeah we're hanging out with him
here yeah pretty cool yeah that's where
the you get they got to feel the love
though like it's like the you know like
when you say when people go see you live
it's uh they they want to be able to
feel that appreciation you have
for them coming out and like that's
like that doesn't need to be taken
advantage of because it's it's a you
know people it's you know expensive to
go see anything or do anything anymore
and so they they want to feel that you
care as much as they do that's a good
point man I gotta remember that
sometimes to let people know that I care
you know sometimes I think it shows I I
it's gonna show I think it shows I've
seen you at your shows and I think it
shows and it's uh
uh there's people that don't have that
and I mean I think a bit big aspect of
Hollywood doesn't have that anymore and
the stuff that they a lot of stuff they
make is so disconnected and it's uh that
it's uh it doesn't translate that's why
Top Gun was the biggest movie because it
was like
not that you're going to relate to it
but it was like you felt the
appreciation of just as a moviegoer to
be like you gave me a fun movie dude
like it was just I had a good time yeah
and it wasn't this giant heavy whatever
thing yeah it was just a good time and
it was a time when everybody needed that
to go I just need to go have some fun
and fun for two hours yeah and everybody
had a blast Tom Cruise does an amazing
job at that with uh that's a good point
yeah all Mission Impossible all that
dude's just a fun dude it's just super
fun and then other movies or these
movies and a lot of times in Oscars
where people are like I've never even
heard of that heard of that and you're
like yeah I get it's probably this
artistic Masterpiece or whatever but
you're like yeah like majority Banshee
or something it's always like if
somebody was gay that we can't ask if
they're gay anymore yeah yeah you know
it was like homo Napoleon yeah like you
know that's a movie I don't know about
it I don't know yeah
Harriet tub women and you're like I
don't know if she was a lesbian yeah you
know what I'm saying it's like they're
just like that's true dude why is
Hollywood got so disconnected you think
I thought the movies in the 80s were
great they were great that was just like
a it was just so they were moving on
whatever and no one I think that now we
overthink everything it's like yeah if
something was potentially offensive like
uh maybe they did they probably didn't
mean it that way they were just trying
to have fun so everybody just didn't
take it for more than it actually was
yeah so now I think we're just so
hypersensitive they're not yeah I don't
think they're uh
like related relatable or like there's
not used to go I think go to the movies
and you could be like that was you in
the movie you could relate to it you
could see yeah
uh you know Ferris Bueller's Day Off
right like is like it's like a kid
that's skipping school and it's an
extreme version of it but it's a fun
version that's vacation yeah vacation is
like everybody's been on that vacation
you know what I mean family just gone
that's why I think I was wrong was so
big because Entourage was just like yeah
if you made it and you're like this is
me and my boys how would you we made it
and you're like we'd be like that we'd
be they they were living it up and there
that's why that that that show and that
even the movie like every like dudes
loved it because it was just like yeah
dude that would be us yeah and you
wanted to live through that right uh
that's what we made stuff so and I loved
it too because they always did the thing
where it's like we didn't get it uh we
can always go back to Queens and just
chill as boys and then wait a second we
did get it I love it and everybody's
like it's just like you know it's coming
but it's just like it's just nice it's
nice it makes you feel good yeah yeah I
went back and watched on the whole
Entourage oh Entourage I've never seen
it oh it's great I'm saving that for
when I get a little bit older I think
there's some some series I'm saving the
wire
Sopranos yeah
um Malcolm in the Middle
and what was one you guys just said
Entourage Entourage yeah those are four
big ones that I'm saving
uh I'm trying to think of what else I'm
saving you guys saving anything
uh I I watched the wire and that was
that was that was a it was a lot I
didn't really like it was
I need to probably go watch it again it
just feels like a whole thing I was
really blown away but I really thought
it was college educated I thought it was
the greatest thing yeah it's probably
for us it's probably for a smarter crowd
yeah but um I just thought it was
unbelievable and I thought The Sopranos
was really good but the wires just so
well done yeah and didn't get their
credit and deserved at the time
obviously
the wire dude no not at the time when it
was on it didn't get the credit but
afterwards people were like it's
brilliant you know it's a it's a great
show I mean most people not not you I
think it's like it's supposedly great
it's great
I think it it was just a lot yeah it's a
lot of talking right yeah it's a lot of
talking it's a lot it's it's an
intricate story but the guys were
writers in Baltimore the guy the guy who
um created it was a beat writer in
Baltimore so that's why it's like you
could see like that guy like actually
knew what was going on instead of like
most cop shows which is a caricature of
what's great you know yeah so oh that's
interesting I could have met I could I
could I could see that excuse me yeah I
could see that's interesting I Used to
Love In the Heat of the Night was a show
that I loved and then I always
romanticized
um a Little House on the Prairie I love
that yeah I remember watching that I
love that TV never really watched it I'm
aware of it but I never won ah dude yeah
it was yeah when you guys in Nashville I
guess you don't know what we went
through did our sister got kicked out of
the horse
that's like a Nashville show or a
southern uh Southern uh rural it's a
rural show yeah probably yeah
if it's uh we watched that it's probably
a rural show I went to the Statue where
they have Andy Griff to bring that up
they have there's a statue of Andy
Griffith
um in Raleigh or Charlotte yeah I want
to say raw uh Mount Airy yeah but man
area is like kind of close to somewhere
but there he is oh no that's uh that's
Barney
yeah there you go yeah I was just
talking about Ron Howard's got a pretty
wild career
he has huh I mean just to be on that
show yeah you're on this you're on the
GI this gigantic show to go to Happy
Days yeah to then start directing movies
that are the Happy Days was really great
huh Happy Days was yeah were you
entering College when that came out and
it was like kind of a rebirth for
Italians I feel like was it the Fonz
yeah oh the fans was the best was they
were they Italian or I used to telephone
my clothes used to be a fine job yeah
yeah
I used to have this funds joke it was uh
oh did you guys hear what happened to
The Fawns he got AIDS
and uh if I it didn't end well man
and some woman one time we yelled out
like I have AIDS everybody's like what
the [__] yeah something about you this
yeah
oh my God this is about Italians yeah
yeah Jesus how fun yeah I mean what are
you doing be smart don't start kick the
habit put it out before it puts you out
those are all phrases we've heard a
hundred times yet we continue to still
have bad habits dang
our sponsor fume is on a mission to
accelerate Humanity's breakup from the
bad habits that consume far too many of
us
fume is not a vape
fume is a natural diffusive device that
uses plants and Behavioral Science to
help you trade out your negative habit
for a positive one
that's right fume's new version 2 model
is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap your fingers will
always have something to do it'll keep
you busy
head to try fume and use code Theo to
save 10 off when you get the journey
pack
the journey pack comes with three unique
flavors and the new version 2 fume to
help kick start your positive habits
that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code Theo to
save an additional 10 off on your order
today I'll say this it is worth giving
this a shot if you're trying to kick a
habit
this will help hello
fresh that's it baby hellofresh
when you're two two things are too
hectic
Mama's running around little Lance needs
to go to the uh bakery or something and
Mama's got to get him over there and
Danielle's got a softball game or
something
and she's not that good at it but you
guys are taking her to play anyway y'all
are busy family
that's why dinner can't overwhelm you
that's right make Meal Time easy with
hellofresh
they offer delicious recipes made with
fresh wholesome ingredients delivered to
your door no lines no hassle just great
tasting meals you can whip up and enjoy
in the comfort of your home hellofresh
has 40 weekly recipes to choose from for
all meal occasions Lifestyles and
preferences
take your pick from meals like soy
glazed salmon with rice or mushroom and
chive risotto I had the risotto man
I love risotto they did it right
delicious dinners are a sense with
hellofresh Chef created seasonal recipes
powering up with protein is easier than
ever
just check the protein smart tag on
their menu to quickly find recipes
featuring 30 grams or more of protein
like one pot pork and black bean chili
or creamy Dijon dill chicken it's really
easy you go on the website you put in
the ones that you want and Bam hello
fresh it's delivered to you and it's
delivered fresh you're getting seasonal
ingredients picked at Peak ripeness for
Quality you can taste
ingredients travel from the farm to your
home in less than seven days so you know
that they're fresh
it's so easy man you open the box you
put away the ingredients bam when it's
time to cook the card is right there it
shows you exactly what to make do it
with the child do it with Lance do it
with Danielle or just do it with your
spouse be romantic or do it by yourself
and be solo romantic and treat yourself
well later on
go to hellofresh.com
theovan60 and use code theovan60 for 60
off plus free shipping that's right go
to hellofresh.com
slash Theo Von the number six the number
zero
and use that code theovan 60 for 60 off
plus free shipping
hellofresh baby it's it's good oh you
got a p or not
now I can hold it now he's good I wrap
my head around it yeah yeah all right
he's just mentally tough yeah mentally
he's a big uh mafia guy too I love the
mob I love uh I I because all these guys
have podcasts now right oh yeah all the
podcasts and stuff and I'm just
fascinated by what it was because I
followed it when I was growing up you
know I'd read all the books and
everything and then uh and now what it's
become with all these guys having
podcasts it's just it's really something
yeah what's a good one if I want to
listen to some mobbing and stuff like
that what's a good one to get into well
I think that it goes the highest the
higher ranking member that you are when
you flip the bigger the podcast it is so
like Sammy the bull I watch his it's
fascinating graviano is that him gravano
gravano yeah
um that sounds like some kind of a gravy
that you would get in graviano yeah you
would ask what that is at the restaurant
you go what's this gravyama you gotta
look it up yeah I'm like yeah like it's
French yeah
we can't afford it yeah yeah but he was
like one for the table he was up
if you don't mind splitting that
appetizer
he was the underboss of the gambino
crime family he flipped in like 1990 91
and uh so and he did he got out of
prison in five years because of his
cooperation but then he got caught an
ecstasy ring in Arizona and went back
and did 20 years and then he got out so
now he has this podcast and he's telling
these stories and they're just riveting
so he was a very high ranking member
plus uh John Gotti Everybody Knows His
his name he is a big name recognition so
um
he's the probably the most highest
profile guy because he was an underboss
of a huge crime family but Michael
Francis is another guy who was a Colombo
um Captain so the the higher rank you
are I think the the bigger you're
following is coming up when you flip do
you have to be pure Italian to be in the
mafia they had a rule where it was uh
for a long time that you had to be
Italian on both sides I mean way back in
the day I think you had to be Sicilian
on both sides
um but then Italian on both sides and
then as I think now it's your father has
to be Italian because you become what
your father that's the way they look at
it and what you're fine but are there's
and they're still they're not act like
now it's not now it's like they're they
don't kill anymore there was a thing on
the commission where they were like not
because they're more more Peter got to
them yeah what's the commission the
commission is uh the the bosses of the
five families in New York and then
families from other cities they sit on
like a national commission and decide
policies for the entire Mafia in the
like it's like an Elk Lodge they meet up
like Knights of Columbus yeah the
knights are going on I think I did a
show for them
do they is there still the mafia there
is but they don't they uh I I don't know
what the word this is uh in your weight
loss because I don't know what the word
what's moratorium oh moratorium yeah
what's that mean I think it's a
moratorium on killing which is like they
don't do it anymore they don't they
don't kill anymore and it's not because
they're moral
is it more a temporary probate I use it
right okay
yeah so it's a moratorium on killing
which is which means
it's not because they're moral people or
anything it's just that they'll get
30-year sentences for murder like if
there's a murder conspiracy or something
if they get charged with racketeering
you know or gambling they might do five
years seven years and these guys can do
five and seven and ten years like that's
not a big deal to them but if it's if
there's a murder conspiracy wrapped into
that it automatically goes to 30 years
so they and because there's so many
Cooperators now they go okay it's not
profitable for us to kill each other
anymore so what they do now I think is
they just put guys on shelves it's
called putting a guy on a shelf which is
they just don't talk to him anymore and
he's not allowed to be involved in any
mob activity wow so it's interesting
time out kind of yeah yeah it's like a
time out but they could have been doing
that all along
we didn't have to kill anybody ever yeah
that's what we don't realize sometimes
what would we talk about now if
throughout history they hadn't all been
killing each other if they'd have been
just time out it would have been yeah
you wouldn't have taken them serious
where you gonna put me in timeout yeah
and he goes yeah yeah I will but the
thing about that is I don't know how
they threaten each other now it's like
you owe me money the whole big thing I
had over these like you better pay me or
I might kill you yeah you know with like
I say I have like a dangerous reputation
so now that people know it's like oh
there's no more killing it's like I
guess I could hurt you yeah
that's true yeah I could tweet it I
could cancel you yes maybe they could
threaten that right they're gonna just
put it out like this guy's talks about
women pretty roughly you know like tone
to that to me dude don't do that I have
a family
I have daughters he goes well yeah yeah
they they could is there but is there so
what are the mod what's their crime now
it's mostly gambling even though
gambling is legal loitering they're not
doing anything anymore yeah yeah
can you make money on lootering
loitering it's loitering loitering
um is gambling and they still have Union
um corrupted unions and stuff and like a
lot of uh trash and recycling yeah yeah
recycling's always a loose you're like
what is
recycling or I don't know if I believe
in recycling well some weeks they pick
up the bin some weeks they don't yeah
what are they doing you ever see uh
Elena's airport has a recycling thing
and it says like paper uh or bottles
paper and then regular trash and if you
look inside of it it just goes to the
it's one bag it's not separated right
it's at Atlanta's airport and you're
like well we're not even doing it I
think there's cameras to see what kind
of a person you are that's what it's
about yeah and then it affects your
credit score probably yeah that's how
the New York water system is too it's
just all the same thing yeah
I'm over there watching a Lego set going
to someone's house first of all also why
did they have it court ordered why were
they having court ordered people
work at the water facility that seems
like yeah yeah you'd want to protect the
water well you'd want like a technician
or something I remember they put these
goggles on us and I'm out there like
you notice making sure that there's
nothing in it like [__] I don't [__]
know what's in it yeah
oh like yeah you're really doing like
science stuff I guess I mean you had to
like have like a um
like handies and footies on or whatever
yeah and then you were out there and you
were just watching the tanks you know
yeah I guess they have the criminals
basically
yeah yeah there's no background check
yeah this might be mob related yeah this
really could be oh we got dirty water
right yeah that's my [__] mob named
dirty water in the South uh no they
never I mean um Florida but Florida but
uh New Orleans Carlos Marcelo was in
they were actually responsible for the
Kennedy assassination those guys some of
the bosses like uh Carlos Marcelo I
think was one of them who put together
the
um Kennedy assassination wow the guys
who really did it yeah I watched
something on that where it was like
eight it's supposed to be like eight
dudes like a lot more people were
involved than
was like that where it was like they
were transferring guns over to because I
mean that's just too convenient that
Jack Ruby who was an associate of I
believe the Chicago
uh Mob he was in Texas at the you know
in Texas at the time and he you know
Oswald was the Patsy and then he shot
Oswald on TV it's like he was direct he
owned strip clubs in Texas and was
directly connected with the Chicago
outfit so that makes a lot of sense you
think I think it makes a lot I think
they were the ones who did it the month
they were they felt I mean you could
hear them on wiretap they were illegal
wiretaps at the time but they were
Furious that um they they felt like they
got Kennedy elected through their unions
and um and he turned on and he turned on
them with Robert Kennedy as the attorney
just going after them and they were like
and those guys were like not what they
are today they were very very serious
guys yeah and they could get stuff done
they would they would not care they
would not bat an eye at it so I think
they were they were the ones who did it
you know why that really it sounds
really really realistic
than just that some got like then a lot
of other vague kind of Russian
conspiracy stuff it seems a little more
far-fetched yeah yeah that Oliver Stone
thing was like it was like the Cubans
were involved at this level the Italians
were I don't think it was like that I
think it was one group and I think it
was I think it was the mob at the time
and they were just like we've had it
with this guy he's like you know he's
putting pressure on us and you know and
the thing was like oh kill Robert
Kennedy it's like now the whole the
whole thing that they said is cut the
horse's head off and the body will die
which means kill the president and then
his attorney general will be ineffective
yeah pretty good then they kill him yeah
they killed they killed John F Kennedy
yeah but then Robert Kennedy was killed
by Sirhan Sirhan who was not related to
anything Bobby Kennedy's been on here
before he's a friend of mine his Robert
Kennedy's son yeah he uh I think he
might be running for
for the Democratic nomination maybe yeah
because he's a Democrat he's a Democrat
but he's
kind of like a new democrat I think he
would almost think I think that party
needs to kind of like figure itself yeah
it does they've gone off the deep end
yeah yeah you know everything it's like
if you're not like a uh
trans cornrow or something you're not
even getting elected right
yeah I watched the thing with the JFK
there's
uh with the uh JFK like there's like
Shooters like there's someone in a sewer
yeah give her the sewer like yeah
I think it explains it for me it's like
there was gunman in that grassy knoll
and they the way that the the elaborate
way that they set it up I mean just for
for The Disappearance of Hoffa how that
could like that how prominent that guy
was and how famous that guy was and for
him just to be for them just to go he
needs to like he was worn like in the
movie like the Irishman I don't know if
you guys saw that but he was the story
is like he's warned several times
because he goes to prison he comes out
and he wants to take the union back and
his predecessor Frank Fitzsimmons was
the head of the unit and they they love
dealing with him more because Hoffa
would resist them a little bit I'll give
you this you give me this he'd work with
them but he wasn't a complete Patsy for
them Fitzsimmons was just give them
whatever they wanted to Once Fitzsimmons
was in they were like we're just we're
better we're better off with him being
the union president and half was like no
I want my union back and they warned him
several times like back off you're
you're a nice man you have a nice family
back off and he's like I want my union I
want my union and finally they were like
okay
that's that's it and they made this this
guy this level of Fame
just disappear
and they had to know like the heat was
going to come down there was going to be
search from the no body no crime just
nobody talked damn and it's just
whatever it's insane what do they think
they think he's barrier they just
probably burn it I think yeah I think
what happened was
um they killed him at that like they
killed him and then they brought him to
like they were all connected with
legitimate businesses so they brought
them to a mortuary or whatever and had
him cremated and then his ashes was that
fit Simmons No No Yeah I think they just
they they killed him at a in a quiet
like a house somewhere like in the movie
I don't know if that that movie is true
I don't know if that guy the Irishman
killed him right but he was killed at
like a quiet residence which somebody
they were connected to and then his and
then other guys I think the body I think
that's true though that whoever killed
him shot him and left and then they had
a second crew of guys
um take him and just of the body that
way if it's ever prosecuted like they
you know there's two parts yeah there's
two parts of it and then if the
shooter's like well where's the body
it's like well I don't know where it is
it's like because they had other guys
come in and dispose of them that's smart
huh yeah it's smart they were like very
intelligent guy I mean evil yeah
obviously but like very intelligent in
terms of like how they got away with
that and granted there wasn't the
cameras and the documentation that's
required today but
the way they did it is just I mean that
guy was one of the most famous people
in the country if not the world and they
just disappeared him that's crazy I
wonder if I'd be good at mafiosuing
would you think you'd
do you have any of that and you said in
the beginning you got that doll again
when it comes to wrestling yeah you got
that ability to to work hard where would
you have been in the mafia you think
there's three kinds of Mafia guys
there's uh guys who are make up a lot of
money there's guys who were Stone Cold
Killers and then there are guys who are
both which is the rarest
the guys who are Stone Cold Killers
called the money guys it's like oh you
guys are soft because you can't kill
anybody and the money guys go to the
Stone Cold Killers like you can't make
any money you're hanging on to us
because we're making all the money and
um and the guys who are both are like
the most dangerous guys who would have
been both
well they say that Sammy the bull was
both he was a stone cold killer and he
was involved in unions podcast and now
he has a podcast so that just shows you
right there where it's all heading you
know are we going to get to the point
though where we run out of the ability
like we've run out of the time where
anybody's done anything and now we're
all just talking about things that are
being done that's true that is awesome
uh yeah yeah uh that is very true I
think about that uh what did I think
about that recently but because it was
like
you're uh well college is is a point of
you know
I think a lot of college is like
nothing's no one's actually doing
something right it's it's everybody's
there's a lot of talking and there's a
lot of you know but no one's living the
way that they're talking because it's
it's a lot of work I was I'm reading uh
a book The Atomic habits and uh I was
talking to him about it like uh because
I I've tried to build more habits in my
life like I'm like I have a with food
like so I uh I was I weighed like almost
200 pounds or 195 like the last February
Okay and like
is that a lot it's yeah okay for me I
don't have the frame to it was just oh
I'm gonna just eat fast food and
whatever eat garbage and uh and so then
I went hard and lost weight for this for
my special hello world and I got down to
160. okay and then so I'm doing Red
Rocks coming up in May and the whole
point was I started this journey I did
like a before picture at Red Rocks I
wasn't playing Red Rocks Red Rocks but I
was I went there and uh because I was in
Denver doing a show somewhere else and I
took before pictures and then I was like
oh maybe by the time I can play here
I'll be skinny and then I get down to
160 and now I've gained it back and I'm
gonna end up going back to Red Rocks and
I'm not going to be skinny I'm going to
be back to omo not I mean I'm starting
to go I'll be less but you know it's
like my goal did not work out right and
it's very frustrating and very like you
just like kind of like depressed like
just like uh like why can't I just keep
this a good pattern a good yeah why I'm
so addicted to this food that I can't I
spiral out and then I like had the
motivation for the special like you can
get excited about something but how do
you keep that going you know you kind of
I hit the goal of the special I'm 160.
I've lost 45 pounds or something and
then I just now I'm back to 180 and
you're like I don't and you're like why
can't I keep that going in because it's
so hard to actually do the work like to
actually to actually continue to do it
it's very easy I can talk about it I can
tell you all the stuff that you got to
do and you go we got to drink more water
and we got to do all these things but I
can't do it I can't physically do it and
so that book I'm trying to read the
atomic habits is like that guy talks
about habits and you know it's like you
got to just do these things he's very
good at habits yeah like Mike gets up
and does the same kind of thing every
morning he's institutionalized yes you
got to be a suicide yeah that's it does
that and that is something that colleges
show you right it's something that we
don't have and it's hard for us to to
his Comics because you kind of have a
freedom right of like there's no one
really telling us what to do there's not
a boss no we don't have we don't have a
you know someone watching us so that's
going like you can't do that you could
just quit this today and then just No
One's Gonna call me and tell them to
come back to work yeah yeah it's crazy
so when you don't have that you just are
kind of lost you gotta you gotta have it
on your own yeah and it is hard to have
it's hard to have it's the amount of
knowledge that we have now is like it's
that's why I learn everything now it's
like through the internet through
podcasts and through information like I
didn't know I wish I would have known
some of this stuff when I was like
cutting weight or uh training or
whatever like I didn't know like but you
still got to do it you still got to do
it but the thing is like uh I cut sugar
that helped me a lot because everybody's
body is different I guess but mine was
like you have to cut sugar it is because
it's hard at first it's hard for like a
week week and a half two weeks but once
you once it's out of your you realize
it's like oh this is what was addicting
me that's why like I had that the
feeling he was talking about which is
it's uncontrollable I gotta eat I gotta
gouge my oh yeah I gotta eat like
overeat and stuff but that's what it's
like when I feel that now I go oh I've
had too much oh yeah I mean I'll have it
nights and I'll have this little baby
buckets of uh Pringles have you had them
yeah oh yeah damn they're good yeah oh
it's the best yeah I got some the other
day oh and they're so there's just like
eight or nine in there and you almost
feel like it's a little family or
whatever they're all sleeping in there
when you open it yeah you know you feel
like a big giant leg oh yeah stay asleep
I'm gonna eat you there uh it's they're
the best I had some uh the other uh I
just got back from Europe and they were
and I had they had Pringles there my
daughter always eats Pringles but you
think oh I'll just eat
four and then I'll eat a couple more and
then I start eating them two at a time
and then you're just that's crazy
Pringles two at a time yeah it's like a
different dude my head I'm trying to
you're lying to yourself to be like well
it's like one it's you know because it's
one yeah all this yeah and then you just
end up eating the whole thing did you
see um
you know if I have a lot of chocolate it
makes my feet itch to the point where
I'll scratch right through the skin on
the top of my feet wow so I know I
probably shouldn't be having it yeah
yeah did you see this thing speaking of
like two is one there was this
what was this thing I saw about mice
see if you can Google this up brother
about
they took mice like a circle circulatory
system right of an older mice it was
about they're trying to keep people
alive longer right this God just
invested Google like investor in um life
expansion it's like 180 million
here we go yeah oh yeah this guy who he
wants to reverse his aging or something
yeah let's go back to the top let me see
what the heading is
man has invested 180 million dollars to
make humans live for longer that doesn't
feel like enough money
right I don't like at it like you're
like well do you really want it you're
like that's all it costs not that's a
lot of money but everything's billions
now and true like all these crazy
numbers yeah it's like uh as the rich
world I feel like this guy like he's
like I'll give you a thousand dollars to
see if you can make you live you're like
all right I mean they'll try yeah dude
uh Twitter how many mice can you even
buy for 180 million like I mean I
imagine you need a lot of mice well
and Twitter costs how many billion
44 billion
180 million dollars he's going to do
he's going to make us live forever I
don't think you could get the mice that
you need and the scientist like you're
going to be like he's going to be
sitting in the budget room and they're
like look we can either what do you want
to do you want to spend more money on
the mice or do you want to buy a couple
more scientists yeah and it's like you
got to make a decision yeah I think
you've got to go scientists at that
point because a lot of your mice are
going to be running the same game dude I
guess you're helping mice
they have more mice well I think that
well this guy some freaking little uh
Yiddish Frankenstein this dude Sam
Altman
um was this the guy that went to jail no
yeah I thought that's Sam Altman bankman
no that's Sam Friedman Sam Friedman yeah
so a different Jewish kid but still
uh young entrepreneur go back up to the
beginning what did it say this guy
Altman is hoping to achieve the latter
goal with the uh
Altman has described emptying his bank
account to fund two particular goals
Limitless energy through an investment
the fusion power startup helion energy
and extending the lifespan
if so he has 180 million dollars right
God yeah
I'd call I think I'd I would just do
your best to live more in the time that
you have than try to get 10 more years
yeah
well maybe it'll start at 10 more years
and then 20 and then you know build that
way if he extends that and you're the
freaking life God and you're just
granting years to people yeah like
you're out on the street and like people
run up and like I you know I gotta
finish an essay and there's like two
more months he's just granting people
something you know
um but go back to what it said about
mice what was the thing about mice this
is the part that I was trying to get to
um extended life span opens interest in
an extended lifespan came from following
discovery of young blood research which
saw old and young mice being sewn
together so they shared a blood system
the old might seem to be partly
rejuvenated as a result of the
experiment and after hearing of the
apparent success Altman tasked his staff
at the time with looking into the
progress being made by anti-aging
scientists
so that's crazy they basically sewed an
old person in a young old mouse and a
young Mouse together
no you're the old life that's how you
find out you're old in Hollywood Oh no
you're the old mice
takes out his mouth teeth to eat some
cheese he puts in his but is that what
Magic Johnson has been that he's been
getting
he's been getting blood transfusions all
these years yeah he's very healthy so
it's like maybe that's what it is you're
supposed to get blood more
did you know that yeah someone told me
uh
it was like with testosterone if you get
testosterone you're supposed to you you
got to give blood a lot but I think
you're supposed to give blood a good bit
because it helps you get more blood
inside of you all right yeah it's like
maybe I don't know anything other than
someone said that to me are we supposed
to donate blood well here we go this
other thing this guy said
plasma there so if you get young blood
and put it in you maybe that's oh
Youngblood sounds like something a
Brothers say to each other yeah Young
Blood I think they do say that to each
other yeah you know if you're in the
gangs
is The Gangs of the new mafia the game
yes the gangs would be the gangs the
gangs are dangerous but but the gangs
are just dangerous the gangs are like
dude I think if the Bloods or Crips came
out with merch bro
they would cry like how do you not have
[__] merch yeah yeah
it's got to be blue and red like basic
merch it's not even yeah you don't need
like refrigerator magnets or nothing
look at the handkerchiefs right I mean
you're you're going yeah you guys should
be
uh patented that you know yeah you can
sell drugs you could sell merch easy
dude somebody rolls up on you with the
[__] little you know a 70 sack of
sweatshirts but then they get in the
merch game and then that's not fun yeah
that's true then they're all on the
block with these big boxes yeah that's
what yeah and kids sell you m M's or
something like they're they just also
have like a hat you gotta take uh some
peanuts and maybe two of those hats yeah
I appreciate it the cops are like hey
you got anything on yeah
this is unlicensed
we call that in New York you know when
you buy purses or like on the street so
supposedly you're supposed to buy from
the guys that have them wrapped in a
blanket because those are the ones that
they get in trouble for selling so like
the guys that are on the sidewalk with a
us you know with like a table or
something that are going to be able to
sit there all day well they have
permission to be there you need the guys
that have them all wrapped in a blanket
that if a cop comes they gotta go all
right so see you and then they gotta run
off so that's what I always heard you
want to buy from them oh yeah they're
trying to really trying to hide
something yeah yeah yeah you need
someone that can go to jail it's got
some skin in the game I respect that
yeah
um yeah I was thinking uh what were we
talking about the gangs are dangerous
but instead they just pretend like they
own real estate they don't own [__]
[__] right
they're kind of doing shitty business
the Bloods like they like we own this
block and it's like next you know a
bulldozer shows up and they're [__]
gone they're like we don't know they
need to get in the well they probably
would need organization like the Mafia
the mafia oh yeah it's like they have
legitimate like the the thing about the
mafia is one they're ingrained in normal
regular Society so they have legitimate
businesses they were involved in
politics
so they had all that they would take the
illegal money and like put it into legal
places and illegal places they were just
like but it doesn't seem like the gangs
do that you know what I mean it seems
like they they need like the white
collar end of it to be like funneling
the money and making you know yeah they
can have wealth they need the partner
they almost need that other Mouse to get
sewn next to it yeah yes yeah they need
a healthier Mouse in some ways like if
the I feel like if the Bloods and or the
Crips and the Italians and the mafia
Linked UP they they are at some level I
think some of the families have like the
gangs they work they do work together do
Italians and black people work well
together do you feel like has that has
ever been like Italian versus black
people beef I know like Chinese and
black people don't get along great yeah
and somebody said like aliens and black
like black people have beef with aliens
or something but uh even the aliens are
like they can't even come down here and
be like good dude like I don't know what
happened I just heard that bro that
means if we're gonna watch Alien movies
about with black people liking being
like they don't even you're like come on
Black Version
yeah oh that would be very fun but
there's a lot of like it's like Snakes
on a Plane yeah the same kind of vibe
yeah yeah
uh yeah there's a lot of like Street air
beef I guess between those parties but
yeah I just wonder was there always was
ever like I think the whole common thing
is because a lot of
um with uh black gangs and with also
there's the thing in New York now with
albanians who come into Italian
controlled family territory and they
start gambling operations and they're
you know Albania is like a war-torn you
know very tough place to come from so
the Italians are like you better not do
that in the Albania is like or what
right you know and then just kind of
like yeah bring it you know we'll we'll
fight you and you know the Italians like
the street Italians are like on the
downswing now because we're just you
know third fourth generation yeah and
the albanians are like first generation
just coming from a war-torn area so
they're just like don't whatever don't
make loud noises on your hands who he is
that's who he is he's on the [__] mad
he's a [__] sorry yeah he's a hit man
it's the fact that you let him drop like
anchors
you lift them and then you just go and
you just drop them like there's no
control I don't know how you accentuate
making a point
is that you the Italians have you're
Italian you have heavy hands imagine
when you're his parent he wakes up in
the morning
like a 60 year old man going down the
hall yeah you just hear the steps when
you would walk around upstairs with your
family because you you have the strength
to lift it but then you just let
everything fall yeah yeah they're like
how's Mikey doing like seven months yeah
he's up yeah yeah
there's no question no uh did you see
yeah now like all a lot of the mafios
it's even Tick Tock did you see this guy
this kid Big Joe signaro can you look
him up on Tick Tock Joe you know what
I'm talking about
see if you can find him it's like I
almost started like even with like
episodes of Dateline there's no more
murder because there's nobody but I
think the Italians like they're at a
point where it's like there's all these
guys doing podcasts everybody's a
cooperator there's cameras there's bugs
everywhere the RICO statues put them in
jail for like 30 years so I think the
guys on the street now like and I don't
know I just watch all of this stuff but
it's like I think they just want to
quietly make money yeah they just want
to quietly make money and live in Staten
Island or Long Island or some parts of
Brooklyn and they just want to quietly
make money and just live their lives
they don't want any kind of like they
don't want like a guy like Gotti coming
in who's flashy or anything like that
they just wanna and they don't wanna
like a war with any they don't want to
war within themselves they don't want to
war with other groups they just want to
quietly quietly make money yeah who is
the guy that oh was it the old guy that
was super who was the best mob guy
I bet he knew Babe Ruth yeah Carlo
Gambino it's like how much over how many
years can you be successful and on top
and and the big thing is how did you die
if you died in your bed that's a win and
not in prison or getting shot in the
face so um Carlo Gambino they say was a
you know he he was the boss of the
family for like 30 years and then died
in his bed in like 1976 and um that
there's a guy from Chicago
um
I forget his name he he ruled Chicago
for like since from the Capone days to
like the early 90s
and uh and he died in his bed and that
guy might be the most successful
he might be the most successful because
no one even really knew him no they they
knew him on the street but they they
tried to drag him in and if you could I
don't know what the guy's name um from
he's from Chicago his name was his
nickname was the Big Tuna the Big Tuna
from Chicago let's look him up huh yeah
and they tried like they brought him in
for like a Senate Judiciary they
subpoenaed him and uh they brought him
in yeah Tony Accardo there so they bring
him in and he talks and then they keep
trying to bring him in but he just he
they can't get anything on him so the
last his last hearing it's actually very
funny I don't know if you could bring it
up but the last hearing it's like he's
like nine he's like in his late 80s and
they bring him in and they're just
asking him questions and he's so old
that he can't hear half the quest I
watch it I'm laughing it's on YouTube
yeah it's on YouTube but he like it just
shows you that he beat the system he
spent like two days in prison his entire
oh life and it's just it's a it's a
fascinating thing to watch that the guy
is
there you go right there
do you recall when that was taken
uh do you recall what you were doing uh
at that time
were you yeah business meeting with Mr
Sharon not sure good answers completely
unaware of what uh what he does for a
living not sure
so they think this guy did stuff like I
mean that guy was from all like an
informants and stuff and like the video
FBI information that guy was the head
like on the top like he probably retired
and was overseeing it that he had with
the Chicago uh bosses would do and in
some of the New York guys they would
have Street bosses so the real power
would because too much heat he would
step back and then have a street boss
take over that was like Sam Gianna and
Joey but some of these other guys they
and they ended up like uh Sam giancon
ended up getting murdered in his home
but um a lot of these guys ayupa and
Saron who they were talking about ended
up doing life sentences and never
flipped you know so they ended up doing
life sentences so they would put a
street boss in place to run things from
day-to-day operations but like on big
policy questions like that guy would be
consulted so that guy was there to take
his ego out of it yeah and that's what's
safe I mean after a while you have
enough money to be like what am I you
know I have enough money I don't need
the heat I don't need the legal
headaches so I'll just step back and let
let somebody else run and just that guy
probably have people killed and all that
I'm sure Sam giancona like the only way
Sam giancana who was the boss of the
family like for a while in the 60s and
the 70s
um for him to get killed had to be
okayed by him it had to be okayed by him
there's nobody higher right you know so
it's pretty it's pretty fascinating the
structure also another thing that
fascinated me is guys being walked into
a room and they're not sure if they're
gonna die in the wedding and they go
yeah yeah and they go anyway oh yeah
they have to because you're so scared
and the in-laws paid for it yeah that's
the [__] yeah that's how they get you
the wife's Deadpool that's why they pay
for it yeah there's no old thing with
trading a goat or whatever it's because
it's another linchpin for you to feel
responsible to be there yeah God that
breaks my heart it's really great that's
like when you're yeah when someone
orders oh the appetizer and you gotta
you gotta eat it you go to big Italian
family you got to eat she keeps bringing
food out yeah you have to eat it to be
played and that's what marriage is yeah
she's trying to be polite then they will
have their daughter who's had a couple
few too many apps as well and you're
[__] like all right I've already
eaten everything else I'll have a little
bit yeah
all right I'll take her in yeah
and she's the goat yeah that's the old
thing he's the goat that'd be a good
movie She's the goat she's the goat and
it's like a girl that kind of sounds
like a ghost you think go the word the
the the label goat is uh greatest fall
time is is pretty annoying now I think
it's being so overused that it's taking
everything from what it was right I mean
Tom Brady was a goat and then he just
kept goading so much that he like he
well we've lost it right yeah we've you
but we've and we've used it now
everybody's calling everybody go
something and then people that are goats
are you know they they say they're the
goat too oh yeah that's crazy and then
you're like LeBron calls himself the
goat yeah yeah you get [__] hey you
want to let other people say it you you
do that's old Mafia that's what the guy
we just watched with you he never said
he called himself to go now he lets you
young Mike young could you be in the
mafia absolutely not I know but like
blood was bloodwise I could yeah yeah
wow yeah
you think you would be farther along in
your career if you would have
absolutely yes that would have that's
the most that's the most yeah if you're
in a mafia I'd like to be like a Sinatra
like Sinatra wasn't in it but he was
adjacent to sang to him and yeah he sang
to them they loved him and like if he
needed a little bit of help they would
like muscle or whatever that would have
was he full Italian
uh Sinatra was here yeah wow yeah
Hoboken
I wonder if um
yeah I wonder if I could have Mafia or
not if I could have handled it I think I
would have gotten I would have fallen
asleep on a little mesh and like the
first and third mission to give you a
couple bucks to go you know run over to
Eddie's and get a [__] a couple cuts
of Salama or you know Salam or whatever
and then I'd have [__] it up dude I'd
have slept well it's good stuff up it's
good to mess early because then they
won't count on you it's when you mess up
the stuff like there's just stuff that's
like a death sentence where it's like I
didn't you know if you caught dealing
any kind of drugs supposedly it's like
it's that's death you screw up if they
tell you to go like your order to kill
him and you don't kill him then they
kill you and him oh that's the worst bro
you get back in the car and you haven't
killed the guy yeah and now you got to
go back and pretend you're a plumber
again well yeah you almost got to go
tell the guy look
that I was supposed to kill you man I
didn't because I just don't have the
heart to do it and then you gotta hope
that that guy doesn't kill you know but
you go like I'm telling you this they're
going to kill us both right so then
could you go into hiding that's a good
move tell the guy look yeah right now
it's gonna suck but you're gonna have to
leave that's what I think you would be
in the mafia you would have got to you
would have had so you would have got to
the level of you to just end up having
to talk to the guy and being right yo
can we get out I go back up yeah and
what do you got to do can you get out
ever
I mean these guys have I mean Michael
Francis was the one guy who like never
cooperated and just is out there's
there's a couple guys like that who
never because but you're not supposed to
be able to get out you take that you
take his Blood Oath where it's like yeah
you're never getting out but those guys
managed to get out and these guys early
blood with like two in me yeah yeah
early blood
23 and me on you now now they do it 23
million oh it's going up bad yeah yeah
you have it you're supposed to take a
Blood Oath that you never but there's
guys like the guys who cooperate now are
not in witness protection anymore
they're just coming back to their old
name they're living in the neighborhoods
where they were wow when they were
active and they're doing podcasts which
is kind of unbelievable that nothing
happens to them yeah I think it shows
you how far it's gone you know how far
it's kind of dissipated in the sense
that they want to do Street crime well
it's probably history now and you want
to you want to be able to like document
it yeah you want to be a document and be
like we're not doing those things
anymore so it's probably okay for him to
talk because then even if they got
caught you're like a guy they put guys
they put guys away for 30 years for life
they put all these guys in prison and if
you're in a mob and there's a
Brotherhood and you know you put my
brothers in prison for 30 years it's
like I don't know I guess I could just
go well that's the life now and I'm not
gonna risk an attempted murder on a
federal witness because I'm gonna put
myself in Jeopardy then um sit in prison
listen to a guy was a podcast who did
the same things that you did and he's
not getting in any trouble or nothing
he's making money yeah and now you have
he's doing ads he's yeah he's doing yeah
he goes all right 23 and me everybody
check it out liking your you're just in
prison stewing yeah yeah Larry's vodka
sauce
uh and now you got God this is like the
new kind of like Mafia it's on Twitter
go to one of the good there you go this
guy
let's turn him up and start it over Big
Joe sagaro
oh slick tone Big Joe what's the quote
of the day life gives you lemons make
orange juice
that's what he does that's what he does
he tells you quotes that's the same one
hey slick Big Joe what's the quote of
the day there's no such thing as good
and bad money it's just money
that's it walks away
he well I think he has somewhere to go a
lot of times or something where he has
like uh incontinence Hey Big Joe slick
tone what's the quote of the day
hey
how's Big Joe doing
I'm doing great probably thank you for
asking
what happened at the beginning of that
video I think that still yeah it just
shows you where the mafia is yeah
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a good one yeah yeah you got to
respect Big Joe cigaro man I don't know
where he is I don't know if he's a child
or not but uh that's where they at he
looks like a yeah that looked like high
school it could be yeah like is he in
yeah they go to middle school maybe I
don't know yeah with Mafia kids go to
school they would yeah where'd they go
they can't go to regular class you can't
have [__] you know uh you know Benny
the shrimp sitting there and [__] is
it looked down on if you go to a
community college if your kid is in
community college is that not if you're
Al Capone and you go how's your kids
doing again he's in Community College
you go
is that not good yeah it'd be better to
not go to not go usually you go to um I
mean they used to go to the military
that was a thing they go to the military
and and then come out and then
be able to like kill and stuff oh
because they they they're trying to kill
them yeah do you guys think that we
should have a separate gay and straight
military ever like we should have an
all-gay military hmm that would be
colorful I think it'd be cool almost but
I don't I guess I guess in the military
the people don't care I don't I don't
ever hear any of my military friends
saying there's any issues if people are
gay or straight in the military no I
don't think that matters I've heard
Outsiders kind of have thoughts on it
yeah I never heard anybody inside of it
have thoughts yeah but they have a whole
gay military that'd be sick huh yeah
it'd be flag heavy yeah it'd be a lot of
parades yeah the flag team would be like
it's like everybody can't be on the
fight like we have to have some they
have to go all right I did a uh it's
hard
to do this yeah
guys not everybody can be on the flag
can I use a word for the gay military
amazing I think it would be amazing
I think you can use that I would love to
see uh I I think we're going to get to a
point soon on television we're gonna
have a lot more gay prize fighting you
know when I was growing up they had this
group
um and we'll bleep this word out but
they had this group that would come to
the one of the bars in Baton Rouge it
was called fist fights was the group and
they would have game it was it was gay
men put it on and you pay five dollars
to go watch and you could drink and it
was gay men uh fighting each other would
they have the like dispute about what
they were fighting that's a good thing
about a gay fight it's a good point the
dispute is before they fight like we're
fighting over right like this is about a
men's blouse or whatever yeah yeah yeah
it is very funny right before they
started the fight they gotta tell you
what it was it's a brief statement about
what it's about yeah yeah this is for an
oyster dressing recipe uh this is for he
still hasn't come out to his parents oh
yeah and then like I bet that's a big
well and then
yeah you have to go over there and
pretend you're [__] just a friend all
the time yeah well in gay fighting I
think it's not coming out of the closet
it's coming out of the corner yeah I
think that's oh yeah Ronnie won't come
out of that corner right yeah yeah
dude I feel like
um that's got to be a huge thing huh
yeah if you're a gay man and you got a a
husband or like a little pretend you
know whatever the legalities are where
you live like a suit you know a partial
husband and you he and you have to
pretend he's your buddy all the time
yeah why do you always bring your best
friend to Christmas yeah because he's my
best friend yeah and why do you always
get him a shaving razor for Christmas
yeah
yeah every year yeah but what do you
think is more jolting to a family it's
like um
um I'm I'm gay or it's like I'm vegan
and I can't eat any of this
oh you know I think the stuff okay yeah
what's that stomach gaze did was there
gay Mafia people I'd imagine that's
that's a tough I don't know that was a
thing not to spoil The Sopranos for you
but there's a there was one thing that
was based on in in New Jersey there was
a gay
um I think it was a high ranking member
and they killed him
they killed him for being gay yeah
that's got to be the worst man if
somebody killed you for being
something you couldn't control being
right yeah yeah but I think you just
can't go getting that Mafia you know
yeah it's like you can control that yeah
you gotta that's true huh Italian mob
open to gay members as long as they
don't parade it in public who do they
have a publicist
who did they go to the Italian mob that
uh they got a spokesperson uh even the
Italian mob has started flying the
rainbow flag a star prosecutor in Italy
has revealed the mafia is now open to
gay men and even as a drag queen in
their midst I could see that but that's
kind of like a new undercover you know
yeah the Mafia Have evolved along with
Society Nicola garateri an anti-mafia
investigator in Calabria told the times
of London gays can be accepted now even
as foot soldiers so long as they don't
parade it in public I mean it seems
crazy that you can put this stuff in the
newspaper to be like so it's but so the
foot shoulders are illegal it's a
they're doing illegal crime yeah they're
illegal it's illegal crimes yeah the
inspector claims to have intercepted
passionate letters between a Crime Boss
and a young lieutenant
um
previously Mobsters risk being murdered
if they were even suspected of being gay
right God that's got to be crazy because
what if you're like young and you're
doing good in the mafia right you're
starting out you're the little guy huh
yeah and you like some colored ties
right like you're you don't even know
you're gay yet yeah yeah you start to
realize it but they're saying even if
they think you are right so what if
you're straight but you love flower ties
right like and you start just you have a
little flash yeah and you're you know
you know because sometimes you see there
could be a guy that you're like I think
that guy's gay and then you're uh right
like you're a [__] he's just like a
little flan you know it's like you know
flamboyant flamboyant like but a guy
could just have that little bit about it
like Christian Leighton almost a little
yeah yeah where you could see like he's
a little too handsome for whatever he
does yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's true yeah exactly and
then you're like no no I'm not at all
but it's like and he puts a napkin on
his lap like this before he eats like
even out of a takeout yeah they would
say that at the meeting when they were
gonna kill you they were like he puts a
napkin on his lap what more proof do you
need
[Laughter]
on his lap but then when they go and
take them in the room to kill them do
they even do you even know what's
happening or it's just no but like I
think it's fascinating these guys are
walked to their meetings and they're
like this might be it for me yeah and
and they go anyway they go like some
guys knew they were like the Donnie
Brosco that movie like the real story of
that the one guy
um who he was very close to after it
came out that he was a federal agent and
they led a federal agent into the family
one of the guys responsible was called
to a meeting and knew he was getting it
that's why in the movie he leaves his
money and his jewelry in a drawer and
leaves it half open because he knows
he's not coming back wow why does it
have just so someone knows to find it
yeah yeah because there's a lot of Pride
because they wouldn't have been able to
open the door they would have just moved
it and he goes now leave it open some
people see it yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
I guess there's always right you know
you'd almost go you could say the fact
that he went to this knowing he's gonna
die he almost could be like then he
should live because there's no one more
loyal yeah than this guy because he's
coming yeah you go we're about to get
rid of our biggest asset that truly just
got taken we all got taken because this
guy was uh a federal agent but
he's willing to walk to his own death
yes so why would you get rid of that guy
that's a good point at that point that
guy has a lot of freaking pride and
respect yeah yeah who's it for we don't
know yeah that's the issue you got to
sort that out at that point yeah because
he could fight him off I mean he could
do why would anybody not fight him and
that but I think there's a rule like
you're not supposed to those meetings
like when in your call to a meeting like
that you're not supposed to come with
any you're not supposed to come armed at
all yeah but you just yeah I mean this
but they're God there's a lot of
freaking weird why didn't you bring a
gun he goes because they don't they said
you can you they Frisk you they don't
they don't Frisk you you're like yeah so
just carry the gun then he gets down but
you don't understand it's against the
rules to carry the gun and you're like
all right uh yeah that's tough to walk
in the and how many how many times you
got to take them to a normal meeting for
him to not realize that the bad meeting
is coming you know the meeting right so
you have to be like hey we want to kill
this guy so let's invite him to two
three meetings to let them know like
it's normal right and then the fourth
one where you know then he comes in with
like Popeyes and he's got like yeah he's
like what's up can't wait to have this
video he's like God never saw this
coming
back he's singing a song
He's already had his fingers are crazy
yeah he feels comfortable going he's
eating the fries before they get there
this guy has no respect for any of us
dude anybody who doesn't eat the fries
before they get there I don't know if I
[__] respect that meal you know
that's a good last meal Popeyes is it
Popeye's Chicken yeah you got to go bad
on on your last meal you gotta just like
bloat me up yeah yeah I don't think I
would do a St uh steak is played out
steak is played out too I I'm probably
for me I might be going fast food I'm a
I'm a fast food guy I think some
Chick-fil-A sandwiches maybe oh yeah I
think some Raising Canes maybe I think
I'm going when I what I ate last night I
ate my last meal pretty regularly yeah
just yeah it says the guy who just
showed up back at his room at his
starting way starting with yeah I went
before after back to before and uh yeah
but that's a good question like an
electric chair you're getting the
electric chair the next day they give
you they do give you a last meal what is
it yeah yeah that is a good question
Mike I'll go uh
like we don't answer it though you
should go with some ice cream and I
don't know I don't I got a lot of ice
cream yeah I don't like that Dutch
Chocolate I like regular [__]
chocolate Hershey's the Dutch [__] is
like yeah I don't know the Dutch I don't
know how they got this how they won the
thing or whatever but I was just there I
did shows in Europe yeah and we had some
went to Belgium and uh Brussels and this
and the chocolate and yeah it was you
know sometimes it's like our taster just
we need it to be processed like you're
like art it it you know we have the
taste I have the taste of just like poor
South like you're like no I can't handle
the real stuff you need it to be a
little like I need I love that in New
York the government to be involved a
little bit because in New York they go
that's a big thing now is it processed
is that processed what you're eating
it's like well we live in Manhattan so
it's got there's no Farms yeah here yeah
it's like let's be honest I'm guessing
that this casserole has been cut with
baby powder yeah yeah it can be
realistic too we're [__] eating an
alphabet City over here yeah yeah so
let's I could not lie to each other
um did you like living in New York yeah
I did like it I would go back I think
about sometimes trying to you know
possibly doing something else Rogan's
always asking me to move down to Austin
but sometimes I feel like every there's
so many people there already this is it
dude here
um I'm a big Nashville fan yeah and uh
Vanderbilt's doing a little better
Vanderbilt's doing better we got a big
game this week and it's very exciting uh
but I'm a big we have a good comedy
scene here uh I want Nashville to a lot
of comics to move here and uh I know a
lot but Rogan's doing great and like you
know he's got his new club and Austin
does have a great scene but I think we
have a great scene I'll tell you I tell
young uh I talked about young comics
about whether you have to move to New
York now I don't think you when I
started it it was we needed to be in New
York I don't think you have to go to New
York like you did when we started I
think you can easily move to Nashville I
I like young Comics I would like you to
move to Nashville I want to build this I
hope this scene builds up and but you
can be here here Austin's got a great
scene like you do not have to go to uh I
think New York like you did I just I I
really don't think you do because it's
you're going up every night here can you
get up every night here though I'm not I
think if you yeah they get up yeah they
can get up every night here and there's
a lot of great Comics here I agree
there's a lot of guys you know we have
Comics getting stuff out of here they
had uh a girl that she's writing for SNL
I believe was out of here uh Laura Peak
I believe she opens for Louis like she
opens for me Joe was for you yeah she's
out she's from here she moved to New
York though but uh you could I'm not
saying you don't ever move or you know
if it ever changes but I don't think
when you start I don't think you have to
I think you can get seen uh in other
cities now yeah I agree I agree I mean
things about Nashville that are great
are it's a small City yeah it feels uh I
think it's definitely a good starter
city as well if you're considering
moving to somewhere else bigger yeah but
you don't want to make a full jump to
somewhere especially from a smaller
place yes this is a great place and it's
growing so fast I mean mean in five
years it could be a huge City it could
be a huge City I mean it's growing I
mean things that were just built are
being torn down to build bigger things
that's it's just unbelievable yeah um
and you have a lot of friendly people
here like I know my neighbors here I
know people that live on my street it's
like it's
um you have a lot of local support yeah
that's those are some things that are
great about it yeah we have the the
Nashville Comedy Festival is a a giant
Festival yeah and it's they're in it
Carlos yeah uh who else Carlos Miller I
think is in it David Spade are you in it
Carlos Miller who I don't know last year
that's one no yeah
yeah yeah yeah we did a special last
year didn't uh but yeah like I mean but
it's a lot of big names that and so
comedy's becoming a big thing yeah uh
yeah I would like it to become more I
think though probably a new club will
pop up at some point because of just the
size of the population growth yeah but
they have there's so many other rooms
too but Zane but the good thing is
Zanies does a very good thing with the
do the new material night which has
become I mean dude people are it's this
it's sold out and that's just a new
material night and at those nights where
you're going to be there I go there like
it's I mean it's tonight you're going
tonight
yeah so like a lot of like when you
moved here that was a big deal like it
was a it was a big deal for this scene
to just people recognize that there's a
scene here and uh when Steve moved here
and then uh Josh Wolf was here I think
he'd left but it was uh you know they're
coming here and people are coming here
yeah the club Zanies is great and yeah
then they have the other rooms they're I
think there's Third Coast there's uh uh
I'm blinking on the all the names I need
to go experience some of the other local
rooms too oh yeah that's one way where
I'm personally missing out and not going
and doing that as much yeah they're but
also great you get to a level where or
you've done it so much like you were
saying earlier about Mike is just having
done a lot of that road work that is it
really was kind of a different time I
mean I remember 40 weeks a year I'd be
doing you know the three or four day
weekends yeah you know for seven eight
years yeah yeah but I think that's the
kind of the route of uh for being
becoming a great comic now is gonna is a
little bit of that route like you just
you can book yourself or you can do
there's it's I mean look I it's hard
because you always think I wouldn't want
to start now like you know with what I
think what Comics have to go through but
I already started so it's hard for me to
mentally open my mind to go start over
uh so the comics coming up now they're
having to really create their own kind
of ways and uh but it's like being out
being out on the road I mean like
looking like a Shane Gillis like Shane
is someone that uh when I first saw
Shane it was like I remember when I
first saw him I remember just I was like
man this dude is like it's something
else like this guy is uh you just don't
see that oh yeah he's like the best fart
yeah yeah yeah so the best way the
[__] most like he's like uh
uh no he's just like the it's like the
best pitch that his hope that's like
that's everything and he told me about
the best part maybe he said he was in
private school and he would have they
would have class in church and sometimes
somebody would fart in the pews in an
empty church and it was he still will
stop and laugh about the sound of it
yeah it's like hey God what about this
you know yeah yeah so I still even I it
makes me laugh hearing about it so I can
only imagine being firsthand on a on a
on a farm like that yeah yeah God is
straight off the wood [__] you know I
should do it the rhyme and the Ryman has
always had a perfect seating for
something like that they should have a
contest over there I mean like yeah they
could hold it they'd probably diminish
diminish diminish the big one might
diminish the uh uh Legacy of the Ryman
but
there's a big fart at church
[Music]
oh wow
I mean that was crazy that almost
sounded fake yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's insane what does that mean what
God thinks when that happens I think
that sounds like a mortal sin to me yeah
a big one it felt like if it was done on
purpose if it was a little old lady that
couldn't help it yeah you know but oh
that sounds like it was done on purpose
it sounds like the devil pressing that
button that had like the club that's
like
yeah those kids are videoing like those
kids went into that church and they
planned that yeah they found an old
church and they found a place to go do
it and they sat there's a lot of that
that's what I'm saying it's like that
kind of stuff right this guy's probably
setting up yeah this guy could sell 200
tickets somewhere yeah yeah yeah there's
there's uh atheists right yeah but yeah
but he rolls out there and he brings a
small bench out there and he goes out
there and he gasses up with on the bench
and we were on the clubs like suckers
for years and we could have just been
doing Church farts yeah but the
longevity of it that's what that's the
thing longevity you can get people to
come and see you one time yeah but if
you don't give them something they're
not going to come back that's what like
Mike's special putting that out and
there's you're gonna be able to go watch
this special and it's great and you're
gonna watch him and it's got a new hour
and then it's gonna be uh an amazing
show and you're seeing an act that's the
whole thing that I want to build with
this is or not it's not saying I have
anything but it's it's just presenting
comics and stuff to be like we're we're
presenting a full act so when you go
watch this and you buy a ticket to a
show then you go see it live you are
seeing an act you're seeing a proper
Show versus yeah like you can have
videos where these people can sell those
tickets right and then you're like they
can't go do a full show it's hard to
learn how to do a full show that's like
sometimes you know like America's Got
Talent like when they would do stuff
like that then they'd give them like a
fool they give them a year at Vegas
you're like some of these people are
like they've been doing this for six
years yeah
they can't go do an hour like uh he's
like gargling like Jesse's Girl or
something like that dude can't do an
hour they can't do it there's no show
yeah but then you have like the Terry
fader or whatever the guy's name like
that guy won that but like that guy was
doing the thing for 20 30 years like
yeah he was doing it for a long time so
then he goes and ends up signing a giant
deal with I think he died actually but
he was uh yeah I do think he's dead I
don't maybe I'm maybe he's not dead dude
everybody's dead everybody's dead nine
out of ten everybody's dead but then
also no one's dying you ever think that
there are our most famous people have
been famous our whole life Tom Cruise
Tom Hanks these people are just still
making the same like are you I think
it's Scientology is what you're talking
about that's true that's a good point I
think I would get sucked into something
if I ever got near that world they
probably just I'd get you're gonna just
be like you would go clear fast you just
don't you that I think if they're good
talkers you're gonna be in yeah yeah I
got clear at the airport that's not it
has nothing to do with Scientology huh
it's not like I'm recording it's
probably the Gateway yeah I think they
it's very similar because you're in the
train stations and then in New York they
get you with that little thing yeah come
and put the buzzer on you see if God
wants you or whatever you know I'm
talking about they put the little
check the buzzer game or whatever right
and then put evil or whatever on there
and then oh I'm gonna skate yeah really
invite you to the church yeah well I
thought that's if you were struggling
you were already struggling you're in it
then they hook something up to you to
see what your vibration is or something
and that's like part of going clear like
are you I don't know I got the one
that's just all the I don't know if it's
a la carte or whatever but I got it
where they had it all set up right there
oh really one time yeah and they sit you
down and next thing you know they're
inviting you to over to the church
I remember being in New York man
dude first time in New York I remember
getting into a taxi with a couple of
ladies
and they invited me over for some I
guess I didn't know if it was going to
be sex or what it was right
and so we get up to their apartment and
they were lesbian women
and
um so they start and I'm like nervous
and everybody was doing a little bit of
coke you know yeah and I was doing it
and um so everybody's doing a little bit
of coke and that and they start making
out and you know just
showing tit and all of that and I'm just
like all excited and I don't know if the
cops are gonna bust in I don't know if
this is legal I don't know what's good
like it felt like a lot at once you know
I mean my first night in New York City
ever in my whole life yeah and you've
only heard about New York City you know
New York City you know
and so I was like way scared and so
anyway I kind of start making out with
these chicks trying my best anyway and I
the I think because of the drugs and the
nerves I couldn't get erection
so next thing you know uh I'm like I
gotta get out of here you know this is
just it feels a little hot in here right
because I didn't know if they were gonna
mug me I just didn't know what was going
on right I didn't believe this could
really be happening yeah and then um so
I was like I gotta grab something to go
with me I saw they had like a big
little Santa sack of sex toys right so I
just grabbed one of them [__] and put
it in the back of my shirt
because I want to have like a Memento or
whatever you know uh first time in New
York you know yeah yeah something it's
like an I love New York t-shirt it's
your I love New York t-shirt they have
those number one uh foam fingers yeah
yeah
very similar or sex toys or a number one
foam finger so I put in the back of my
pants and then I get over to um then I
went and stopped in one of those bodegas
or something got me a water and stuff
and I think they just come out with
coconut water so you know I'm pretty
hyped up about that but
um I got dad in like an orange or
something and when I'm walking out I
realize that that whatever I had in my
pants had fallen out and I looked back
in there and there's like a kid like a
five or six year old kid like just
swinging around this like wiener yeah
this big kind of purplish wiener and I
was like get me out of this [__] town
bro yeah I can't live like this
that kid is probably his life might be
different now yeah I mean that moment
he's probably making [__] tick tocks
now yeah yeah he definitely did not go
into his his blue-collar world that his
father wanted him to go to and it all
stems from
yeah that story Bodega weiner kid yeah
that kid was probably up late so I mean
he's asking for it yeah I mean it was a
crazy time for a kid to be awake yeah
people bring kids out late yeah a lot of
foreigners too and let's say middle
easterners especially like in Irvine
California if you go to the mall yeah
there's like 1200 Toddlers and infants
out there at midnight yeah wow it's
unreal yeah
yeah there's no bedtime and they're all
dressed to the nines too yeah it's like
a lot of like
um crushed velvet wow
a lot of after-party children yeah
something like that I watched a uh
something like oh like it was like
someone at the NCAA I was watching March
Madness so I was like and we were saying
there's a guy with a baby at the game
yeah yeah and you're just like is there
not you don't have anyone in the family
that's like I'll watch the baby y'all go
to the game
like people just bring you know it's a
very loud it's it's midnight it was it
was the game that starts on 9 40 eastern
time so it's like midnight it's a I mean
looks like a less than year old you know
we're like well we had to bring the baby
you're like yeah but you don't these are
not
just no one else
you know they might have even been
supporting someone we think yeah like
they were watching someone's baby yeah
yeah no no they were like they had like
their brother or their their nephews in
the game but still you're like you don't
have an aunt that's not going you know
yeah I mean back in the old days you'd
be like don't bring the baby down by the
train or whatever you know that'd be
like the only thing that you know it's
like
times that are so different now I don't
think women left the house like the
first year back in the day though now
it's like women are like I want to be
out you know I want to be working by
Thursday and it's like what the [__] are
you talking about dude you do see that
where you can see video people like I
had a baby two days ago yeah yeah Lee
and they're just out and she's yeah
they're back at work they have like the
kids like in a little jar like one of
those like uh kindergarten uh potato
growing things and you're like Jesus
it's just a couple of [__] toothpicks
coming out of it keep it do you think
yeah we could eventually get to where
people just go take a a little longer
lunch break and come back for the baby
they just it's that quick they just pop
it out and then well I think we're in
the last times where you will see people
women actually carrying the child I
think we're so close to the the children
all being in a center and you go there
you get you do the sperm and do the egg
and and then you get that you go back
and you go visit the baby and you see it
but you get it when it's full when it's
ready
it seems like it almost seems if you
look at a woman carrying something like
that in her stomach well I think it's
beautiful and I think it's the way to do
it I think it's so close to that it's
crazy it could be old-fashioned yeah I
think it would be a mistake because I
think that's the uh one of the most
beautiful things about being a mother
and something that you have that nothing
can take totally is the fact that you're
carrying a child and the the bond that a
child and a mother has is uh is is
something that's it's you can't even
really describe it yeah it's it's
something more it's something bigger
than it's uh you know it's a miracle
it's a it's all that but it's like that
is true like they you could probably get
to a point where you're not having to
have the baby because I mean you need to
account for like touch and eye contact
yeah but when the baby's born then they
then they do it but I just leave it in
there yeah you can't leave it in there a
couple weeks late they're gonna [__]
find you or whatever they're gonna come
bring it they would find you people are
like Hey your baby's looking around hey
yeah hey uh you don't pay the bill and
they're like hey we got your baby it's
four and you're gonna and you're like
it's like swimming yeah it's a library
book and then you gotta you're like uh
are you gonna come get it you go yeah uh
I'll get it I'll be down there I'll be
down there I'm coming I'm coming I'm on
my way and you're like God there you go
I have this kid and you just gotta have
a kid and you go down there there's like
a special little procedure in a room
where you get the kid that maybe like
drag a cloth off of it like that like
yeah but it's standing up because it's
so old now and it just like unveils it
and he's like hello and he goes you
forgot about me he goes I know
I've just been so busy
I've been well I was drunk one night and
I thought let's go have a baby baby yeah
and then you gotta go get it dude that
could eat I just think it's getting to
that point it could I've never thought
about it but I could definitely see it
yeah everything's just getting I mean it
said we're advancing so fast you know
yeah we're getting a point where the
mafia is now a high school kid on Tick
Tock you know it's getting to the point
too where it's like
people we just watch things and then
since peop I think imagination is kind
of Disappearing yes so all people are
going to start to do is watch what they
see on their phones like you even see
like there's a lot of videos a lot of
times it's like a black eye like beating
up a kid at school or something I feel
like I don't know if you guys get those
a lot but I get a lot of that or it's
like you'll see like a kid like beating
up a kid at school right and then other
kids see that right and so then it's
like you know that other kids are gonna
start to just rip do what they saw in
the video yeah so now you have kids just
beating up other kids just so they can
make a video and read the comments of
what people say right it's almost like
you're just recreating what we see yeah
so like whatever you see since you don't
have an imagination of your own since
it's
I don't know does it make any sense what
I'm saying yeah imagination is key but I
think the thing is that social media and
all this stuff is killing people's
imagination because it's
um it's
it's sitting there and just being bored
is okay that's what sparks your
imagination yeah you're forced to use
your imagination because you don't have
any other stimulus but now we have
access to all the stimulus so there's no
need to sit there when you're bored you
think something is wrong when it's not
wrong it's okay you're supposed to be
bored yeah it's to work that muscle like
you're not having to work that muscle
right anymore yeah yeah and it'll
disappear over time right there
Instagram's crypto says the app has lost
the soul
well people are just posting
video like none of this stuff is that
like says they're showing the the ounce
of your life that's fun like the you
know that's like man you feel depressed
I can feel it with like sort of like
following you know we follow Comics each
other and stuff like that and you're
seeing other Comics do stuff and you're
like I'm not doing nothing dude am I
nowhere in my career all right because
I'm watching this person's like on TV
doing something and then right you uh
once you realize that every you gotta
realize that like no one's doing
anything really even though we think
we're all doing everything you're it's
either someone's really good at showing
you that they're doing like they're good
at showing you that they're doing
something but it's
because but they're not no one's doing
it we're all just trying to get by and
all trying to yeah like do what we do
and yeah everybody's just trying to get
by bring that back up well that's always
you have to remember that at the root of
all things most people are just trying
to get by yeah you know now their level
or idea of what getting by is and
sometimes it gets kind of greedy or
right you know it can get we all have
those emotions and if this Taps into the
worst part of human beings I think
because even when you're looking at your
own stuff it's it brings up a sense of
narcissism like how many likes do I get
I want more likes and then you start
scrolling and seeing other people's
stuff and that that triggers jealousy
and like I'm not doing as good and you
and that's why there's like so much
depression from this stuff I think it's
it's a it's this fake connection well
with kids for sure okay for kids for
sure but even for us like we didn't grow
up with this I mean it's bad for us if
it's bad for us to have your brain
develop on this is crazy I think well
that's a good question it's like and
this article says Instagram's co-founder
isn't happy with the direction the
platform is taking claiming it has lost
the soul of its original purpose
um
knowing in its initial launch on October
2010 by Kevin Systrom and Mike Krieger
the app grew massively and has gone from
a space for friends and families to
share pictures of their day-to-day on a
feed to incorporating Tick-Tock style
reels a stories feature similar to
Snapchat and the ability to buy and sell
products using Instagram shopping
I mean if you're raising a kid without
this I don't know how you would do it
but uh it's tough with all the peer
pressure and stuff but um if you could
raise a kid without this like to read a
book and like and to have some cool kind
of like mental grit right you're going
to be raising a superhuman yeah because
everybody is going to be on this so it's
like if you can raise a kid without that
and we used to make fun of the Amish
growing up and everything it's like they
actually got it right I think where it's
like just extreme like work and you see
well you've seen how far they are now in
life and but they're also I mean almost
like the Amish was like running like
they're like I'm I'm joking with y'all
I'm not big for them but it's like it's
but yeah it's like it's funny like I
mean look they're obviously doing it
right you're like I mean they're I don't
know where they're at I mean I just
bought a one of those space heaters from
one of them yeah yeah that's nice they
do sell a lot of those like heaters
online yeah they're unbelievable at
Woodwork and stuff I remember what
before I moved to New York I was doing
some marble installation you know I was
like a part-time thing and this is a
real beautiful house wealthy and we are
putting uh me and another a guy putting
the marble in and we were watching these
Amish were doing the woodwork and they
were just killing it well that's what I
noticed yes there I noticed in Europe
going to Europe was they just
everything's so old there in the
buildings and it just feels it's awesome
and it's like they're because everything
started you know so it's all it's been
there for since you go to a building
it's like a foul it's from 1 000 and
it's it's just the their the culture
like feeds into that like you know
you're there's like a tradition that's
held because it's so old that these
families are like you got a grand like
you you have just such great tradition
and uh I don't think we have that
like it's kind of like traditions not
there's not a lot of tradition here and
I'm not saying it's a bad like I it's
it's just a different kind of thing it's
what you were saying earlier it's like
it's a reflection it's a it's a reminder
of what a young country we are oh we're
like a super young and we react in a lot
of ways like a young country yeah you
know yeah and also I think we became the
leader so quick before in or
hypothetical leader if some people would
say like just because I like the
capitalism and the gross GDP or whatever
like we became a leader so fast that
we're losing some of that well they're
the tradition of stuff like oh the thing
that we had was family right and the
CORE family and that's the and that's
the thing that you can see that they and
that they still they have so much of it
because it's it's just been they've
lived in the same place for a hundred
years their family's been there forever
and so our is like you're seeing that's
what made us I think
there was this reason we were so good we
had that we had such a big strong family
thing and then immigrants would come
here and then they would start in their
family and uh when you still see it in
the Immigrant communities I think like
Mexican people I think there's still
like a lot of big tradition and a lot of
Latino families we do have that we had
it but it's like you gotta have family
yeah families would it'll help you keep
tradition yeah I can keep just keep
tradition keeps your yeah it's like uh
in Hispanic or you know it's like uh
Muslim like all these different quote
they they really have the Jewish
Community they it's all about their
family it's all about yeah like it you
you do stuff because your grandparents
did it you did even properly you know
you go to uh about what Jewish people
they have what do they go through yeah
Temple like they're doing that stuff
where it's like we do it because they
want to do it and all that and it's like
some of that is being lost and it's like
that's in the Immigrant communities it's
great because it's like they're you you
know the come to this country and they
still got that yeah for the American
dream so the first generation always
suffers because it's like okay now I'm
in a grit I'm gonna grind it out I'm
gonna have four jobs and then you know
as a result they always preach education
to the Next Generation to make sure
you're educated you know you're going to
do better than I did and then the hope
is that they get and they do better but
in that progression like two three
generations some of that tradition does
get lost inevitably so now you're this
educated money maker and you have all
this wealth but you've lost the
tradition the work ethic that has got
you there yeah you know you're not
you're not passing that down to the Next
Generation the next generation feels
entitled yeah you know what I mean like
uh I'm born with I'm born into all this
wealth you start to take it for granted
versus you're born and gritty and poor
and then you have to like give that
mentality it's like I'm gonna climb out
of this when I don't know if it's
possible to teach that we had a little
Boosie on here and we were talking with
him about it and even like you know
coming up like in an impoverished a
black rapper right I'm coming up like in
an impoverished area Baton Rouge and
like really from the streets type of
vibe and he was saying he can't instill
that to his children he said there's
just he can't he just said there's
something
you know and I don't know what type of
family right you know template that they
have for him but he was saying man it's
hard to just get that next Generation to
go have the same mindset that you had I
think it's also maybe just the cycle of
how things work it's like you know at a
certain point
somebody gets so wealthy and then the
sun is the the dad isn't there to be a
part of the son's life the sun's and
goes kind of crazy inherits the wealth
and loses it all somehow and it all goes
back into the pool you know I don't know
if that's true but everything kind of
has a cycle in a way but as a parent I
think that if you're if you have wealth
and you you start raising a child and
you you have to be conscious of the fact
that you're raising this child in wealth
and everybody has this thing where it's
like I wanted to have I don't want to
have the struggles that I had it's like
no no the struggles made you who you are
oh yeah so it's important that even if
you have wealth that you don't make it
too easy and that they encounter some
resistance because resistance that's
what makes you strong yeah draw a dick
on his back see if he can hide it from
Mom you know yeah we hide my daughter's
breakfast every morning
[__] yeah make her find it sometimes she
doesn't eat happy Easter happy Easter
every morning's Easter
yeah I then give her 400 so you have a
bounce that you don't know you're doing
it right yeah you go yeah she has like
50 Grand right now it's because I've
been doing it all more ever since she
was a baby but yeah but that's she'll be
fine right it'd be great she can't find
breakfast she just orders it out on your
phone yeah delivery well wealth on a
shelf yeah yeah I think you have to have
that uh you gotta have enough like an
obsession like or especially if they
have some you can find something to be
like go find an obsession and then go
try to become good in that field or
whatever it is because then you at least
can have the grind of like you got to
start from the bottom somewhere in
something especially for someone that
would come from that's that has like a
ton of money or something you're like
well go
you know go learn how to become
successful in that field where like the
parent can't help you yeah right it's
like then because then you if you let
the kid just keep quitting and go well
they're not gonna let me do that he goes
all right well the dad can't force into
the top so you're like all right well
then go try this thing over here you
know so you got to be like no no you're
if you love that then go build up and
there's that thing where it's like well
I don't love it anymore and I don't want
to do what I don't love it's like no you
have to it's you have to create the
ability to overcome adversity that's the
big thing you know you have to eat
overcoming adversity is huge and if you
have too many options if you have the
option to quit everything then you're
not going to be able to you know you
have to weather that initial adversity
and it hurts you know it hurts like to
fail and to and to lose so you know you
have to be able to overcome that yeah
that's interesting man I bet it would be
a lot tougher to be a parent of a in
some ways I mean that's insane for me to
really say that but I bet in some ways
it's tough It's also tough to be a
parent if you're a wealthy yeah well
that's a real struggle that's a real
struggle because your instinct is to
make things easier and it's it's wrong
there's a God David Krantz he's I think
it's his name Krantz can you look him up
um he is a therapist that just works
with uh
wealth and families and how it because
it's a it's a big problem apparently in
those families I used to teach kids with
behavioral and emotional problems oh
healthy cdld yeah hell yeah
Behavior disabled learning disabled yeah
yeah behavioral behavioral and learning
crazy yeah baby and I I taught in a city
school I taught in a um a private
um kids get thrown out of Philadelphia
schools which was a residential school
so that was pretty wild because we'd
have to like physically restrain the
kids if they would get out of hand and
then I taught in a city public school
and then a working class district and
then a wealthy and the wealthy one was
child really challenging because the
parents were lawyers and doctors and all
this stuff and they they didn't have
like the common sense to kind of a lot
of them a lot of them did but some of
them didn't have the comments and one
guy was a psychologist and his kid was
out of control and it's like he refused
just to
um discipline him like with just
standard discipline tactics and the kid
was out of control and he like had other
psychologists on the phone and we had
this I was sitting around an IEP meeting
which is what you have with these kids
and all these different professionals
counselor I was the teacher you'd have
the assistant principal you had um
therapists and stuff in there and it was
just like the guy was like I'm like
there's a million dollars worth of
salaries in here right now trying to
figure out like what this kid needs is
the most basic discipline and he refused
to you know he thought he could
intellectualize his way out of it oh we
can think our way out of this like it's
like no no just do it discipline him but
you discipline and be like look I love
you you tell them why you're discipline
him it's like I love you this is why
this is happening yeah because in the
future you know you're going to be
better from it what did the kid have
anything I mean he's diagnosed with ADHD
and all this stuff by but he was just
the kid was just breaking rules and
doing it because he could get away with
it yeah and instead of going hey dude
you can't do that anymore this is what's
going gonna happen instead of just being
very direct with him he's like well is
there some kind of a behavioral plan
that we can get into place like Yay just
when he does something wrong you gotta
discipline him yeah yeah like honestly
you'd be like if you want to give this
kid a chance you would have been like
you gotta hit him or something like you
know yeah how close were you to say that
no but I because I don't think I I don't
think like uh you gotta say that
sometimes yeah hitting hitting is like
uh if you do things the right way I'd
say 98 of the time I mean you're gonna
get two percent Knuckleheads where you
might have to like have some kind of
physical but if you're raising the kid
correctly from the beginning there's
there's a good chance that you're and
you're just implementing like consistent
discipline you won't have to do that
damn man can you do you ever think about
being excited about hitting spanking
your kids in the future yeah you don't
have any children I don't have kids you
ever think about it how are you gonna do
it where are you going to do it and it's
gonna be sold so yeah they'll be it'll
be like they'll turn it on me you're
dead yeah 70 when I was born yeah wow
you'll be like yeah you could be my dad
you can have some his old shirts yeah
it's great I don't have any his [__]
piece of [__] other children took them
all we'll get but we could probably find
it you have 20 and we have a little time
yeah before we get to that point but
yeah that's right so we're eventually
we're fine the shirts do you uh was it
hard to edit the special when you guys
were kind of putting it together was
that did you guys have to pick and
choose some stuff was everything pretty
clear what did it look like yeah he did
a lot of stuff yeah he did everything uh
I did everything I mean everything yeah
so I could think of because I wanted all
I figured you know you know
shoot long and then you could just edit
yeah you know but um yeah I went through
editing for a long time so yeah I did
was real meticulous about editing it but
does it help with that Nate or what is
that yeah I was I was in on it I mean I
think he did it and then Ben Rosenfeld
and Roosevelt
comedian and he he helped me with it he
helped me with a couple of my albums too
so this he he brought an eye into it and
also just we sat down and just went it's
good to have someone you know when you
have to edit your own stuff it's very
hard like it's like you get tired of
watching it yeah it's good to have like
I would I've always done every special
that I've done I've I've sent it to
another com Justin Smith I just sent it
to him Brian Bates uh since like the
Tennessee all my Netflix that I would
send to someone else
because you're like I can't you know
someone that knows your act
uh because it's like it's just so hard
to sit there and you you're you're too
in yeah after a while you don't know if
you're being objective yeah and after
watching it so many times like is this
even good yeah anymore I don't even know
what this is so it's like somebody's
like no no you know they they can be
objective a little bit and you almost
start to hate it sometimes a little bit
too if you just watch it so much you
don't feel like it doesn't have the same
Punch or one day you watch it and your
attitude isn't the best or in a weird
mood right right and I'll attach that to
things quick sometimes yeah it's it's
it's it's very hard to to do it and then
but yeah we went through the whole
process we I mean I did it with I
partnered with 800 pound gorilla too and
so oh yeah they were part of this and so
they they they're they got a great great
team and so then they were sending it
over and uh and just going back and
forth and he's going through the editing
a lot I mean a lot of that was you're
I'm letting him decide you know like I
would go look at it then but it's like
you know you can feel what he's going to
know more than me and right what uh what
to take out and what you know but we
took out but the way we we started at
different like we did some stuff that
was you know it's it's the like the the
the the beginning of it I wanted to get
right into it so we have a little kind
of an opening thing but it's all about
trying to get into the special quick
hitting jokes have a joke that's just
boom right when you start it's like
hitting it quick and uh and then it's I
want to say 50 minutes 50 53 53 minutes
so it's under an hour like under an hour
uh nice which I think is yeah a better
way to yeah I think it's a better way to
go now yeah I don't know why people's
attachments have to be an hour and
especially you guys are doing it that
way you could still then also take clips
and put them out and put them together
yeah yeah there's a lot of material that
we can uh pump out cool man yeah right
and this your first special mic now it's
my first hour first hour yeah on video
two albums before this but I didn't
shoot them yeah uh videos so so it's
brand new I mean all that material even
then is yeah you know stuff that people
will probably want to see as well or
they'll go back to it yeah his album did
really really good yeah yeah yeah like
the album before this yeah yeah the
worst kind of thoughtful did did well
and uh and yeah 800 gorilla too no that
was I did that independent oh it's good
for you yeah yeah but I'm really proud
of this and uh the process has been
great and uh obviously I appreciate Nate
like
bringing me in and directing and all
this stuff so it's um I'm really proud
of it it's been a long road with this
because we've I've been working on this
not just getting it together to shoot it
but also the editing and all the other
stuff it's been 800 pound has been great
yeah so I appreciate them but I'm really
proud of it yeah well it's a big deal
for me to to put something out that Mike
allowed me to be a part of it because
Mike's that great of a comic and so and
then it was just such a long process
because then I had my special come out
and then it was like so we had it was
like had to be pushed a little bit
because it was like mine was coming and
we're trying to get because since it's
going on my YouTube just if my you know
my YouTube bumps up after my special
then it's just more better it's better
for him and uh and for these other
specials and so yeah it was a long
process
to do it but yeah it'll be March 24th
and how what kind of stuff do we kind of
get to know because I remember when I
was sitting there watching I didn't know
Mike a ton I knew from like
um uh big J kind of and just from some
different comedy circles
um but yeah you start to get just like
this sense of who Mike is do you feel
that that's kind of what people will
pull from it yeah I mean we're telling
jokes you don't get to know them you
know yeah well Mike tells jokes but I
mean you see but you also any of you
you're listening to him now then you see
a special it's like he's very similar in
the fact that like it's not far off it's
uh you know I was Joe Mike's you know
it's very serious yeah it's because
there's no you know you're wasting time
you go uh what are we even doing here
that's the thing Mike says to his
girlfriend everybody goes well what are
we even doing
then like there's a lot of but so Mike's
got a very uh
uh it's all it's his own it's his own
pattern yes it's his own pattern yeah
and it it's it's it's a guy that really
is uh uh you know came up came up
through the New York system and and you
know like just I mean a lot of jokes a
lot of like just a lot of jokes and uh
well-crafted jokes and uh tried and true
jokes and I'm definitely a product of
the New York System though so it's joke
heavy but I I you know I like the I like
telling jokes I like it to be personal
you know and um also I love sarcasm so I
I love that so I tell people up front
like now when I'm performing I'm like
look is this a lot of sarcasm you know
get on board with it you'll have a much
better time if you've been on board with
some of the sarcasm and people buy in
and it's great and then it's it's joke
heavy and personal on top of that tell
me like what's the you know it's your
job and your passion that you tell
people now oh
um what I do is I I tell I get up I tell
a couple jokes like I'm a stand-up
comedian it's my job my passion is
coming to towns like this this to talk
to low-income whites about vaccinations
I love hashing it out with the low
income whites
not always gets such a big pop because
I'll start out with like three like
three jokes I'll laugh and it's like ah
this is good it's like let me tell you
about my passion right the low
[Laughter]
and it's so fun to hear crowds
they that gets such a pop dude well they
probably realize then what's going on
they realize who Mike is they realize
exactly what they're going to be inside
yeah yeah yeah
exactly like you're like oh this dude's
like it's great like it's acknowledging
the absurdity yeah of it yeah
that's a great way it just seems like
there's some people low income whites
it's not much funnier than that so yeah
but I love I love going I was smiling I
heard it man it [__] made me just
felt [__] great I'm like I'm a
coastal Elite yeah I've got I'm going to
teach you I'm going to teach you I think
that's great and talking to people about
vaccinations baby that's two that's just
such a funny
you walk in every room you go into like
yeah just talk people about vaccinations
well dude I remember when I did uh take
my special They had they made everybody
like two days before they made everybody
show up with vaccination stuff oh yeah I
remember that because I talked to me you
talk I remember we talked about it
Netflix made you told me that it was a
[__] night yeah yeah and it was like
I remember you hit me up and you were uh
because you don't know what to do and
you're you get stuck in situations like
that and it's and it's uh
that was like such a weird 38 hours
before yeah I'd already bought all their
tickets and everything I wish I'd have
told me to go [__] themselves kind of
yeah but I mean it's look it's it's it's
uh I didn't know you know well yeah it's
uh
yeah you don't want the real but it's a
tough position to be in because you
don't want it to rail the whole yeah
your head is in another place the people
are coming well his entire crowd's not
vaccinated it was eight people showed up
yeah the best part was I said Thank you
to everybody who came out thank you
everybody who made fake fake Max cars
and get out tonight and the place went
[__] right that's what then that's
and that's almost like the thing that
you wanted people to you know it's like
it's like that underlining just go you
know what to do like it was you got put
in this position that they shouldn't put
you in and they did it last second and
it was like what are you gonna go do
you're about to
take this special all this stuff is
being spent for all all this kind of
like Europe really got yourself stuck in
a situation and let me tell you the fact
that you were you almost didn't want to
do it because you I mean you told me
because you literally told me when this
happened and it was the fact that you
were like yo I'll I'll just cancel the
special and it was like look we gotta
you would less logically think through
this and it's like the thing that you
know happened where people were like if
you're not vaccinated it's like within
who gave a fake vaccine you're like just
we all are having to figure out this
kind of yeah thing and then I wish I'd
have just navigated that time period
better it was a hard time to navigate
the whole time yeah you navigated
everybody yeah I mean just for everybody
the whole you know the whole way it's
like
I never wanted I had to fix stuff
because I never wanted to like I'm not
telling someone to do something like I
uh you know yeah but they would do that
but theaters would do that with uh yeah
they would throw it on us they would say
the artist wants the people to be
vaccinated and like I I so I had a few
places that I was like no no no don't
say I'm asking people to be vaccinated
like you want people to Be Like You the
city might want to or the venue might
want to but they would word it because
no one wanted to be the bad guy the
venue didn't want to be the bad guy so
they but the venue wanted it but they
would just throw it on the artist so
they'd be like Theo's saying everybody
needs to be back you're like Theo ain't
telling people to do that you're telling
people but you're wording it like it's
Theo yeah and they would do it like that
I would have I had a couple places that
I was like yo they got a word that like
I'm not saying anything
you're the one that's suggesting like so
if anybody's gonna suggest it it is like
it is what it is like people are still
coming out
you know but it is what it is but put
that on you say it properly don't try to
throw it because they could just do that
it's like if you want to come to my show
you need to be circumcised male or
female yeah and I think that's a bit
they go we go I show them uh you have to
show me proof that you have no
vaccinations and I'm talking down to flu
shot and I go I need to make sure I'm
the older now the new Italian is you
need to be uh you need to have no vax
blood in you so that's gonna be the new
mafia that's the new model the new mafia
is you gotta be I want if like I want
you to be nervous about the measles yeah
you better be I'm scared about him uh
mumps is that a was that one mumps is
one mom says I want to be standing on
the edge of your bloodstream with a
paddle just like like I'm working for
the city you know like I want to be like
I get sentenced to work over there yeah
but you're proud to go yeah I want you
to have local people who are sentenced
by the courts to work
you have a two people that are unfaxed
in your your mafia gang and you're like
what could kill you and you're like
chickenpox common cold flu it will be
wiped out but it's like but there's also
something yeah anything from Oregon
Trail you know yeah the [__] modem
game
um yeah
what else that's it guys I think we did
a lot huh I think we did a lot I think
we've had a nice time my congratulations
man thank you thank you so much for
having me on I appreciate it oh yeah you
bet and Nate thank you uh and uh thank
you buddy yeah I'm excited to see
um what you guys put together man I'm
excited to see it now
um online and you know after having seen
it in person and
um
yeah and then will you be going on tour
right after you have a plan kind of for
it Mike or no I'm just trying to uh get
the word out as much as possible and
just any you know the way I function is
like any road dates that come I just
take you know if it's you know yeah you
got but you got dates lined up your
website yeah I don't know when this
comes out but I'll be in Madison
Wisconsin and uh at um Comedy on State
oh yeah I love the Great Club and then
Tampa Side Splitters at the end of the
month oh yeah
this is gonna be like a special this
podcast coming next year
this will be right after your special's
out so it just came out okay yeah so is
it all right if I just plug my social
media for sure it's at Comic mic V on
all social media platforms at Comic Mike
V repetition helps the low income whites
and um
and also uh I have a podcast called Mike
vecchione investigates it's a fake
investigations show and it's uh also I
talked down to the listeners yeah
condescend them yeah so that's it's fun
it's a new mafia dude yeah so people
want to hear those hands they can go to
your podcast and listen to [__]
gravity is that your whole podcast is
just loud like
my podcast is called take it out and
post
it's Mike vacchio investigates
awesome Mike and Nate thank you guys for
hanging out buddy you're the best dude
thank you thanks for having me
[Music]